ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 1a
und 1b zweite und dritte Beratung des
von den Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90
die Grünen und FDP eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurfs zur Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes und weiterer
Gesetze
anlässlich der Aufhebung der
Feststellung der epidemischen Lage von
nationaler Tragweite sowie zweite und
dritte Beratung des von der Fraktion der
cdu/csu eingebrachten Gesetzentwurfs zur
Verbesserung des Schutzes vor
impfpassfälschungen
zu dem Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP liegen
einänderungsantrag sowie ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion
cdu/csu sowie einen Entschließungsantrag
der Fraktion Die Linke vor über den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen der SPD
Bündnis 90 grün FDP zur Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes sowie über die
[Musik]
entschließungs-csu werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
67 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne damit die Aussprache und das
Wort hat für die SPD-Fraktion Sabine
Dittmar
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren gemeinsam mit
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen vom Bündnis
90 die Grünen und der FDP haben wir in
der vergangenen Woche eine Gesetzentwurf
zu Änderung des Infektionsschutzgesetzes
vorgelegt wir haben intensiv darüber
beraten welchen gesetzlichen
Ordnungsrahmen hier für die kommenden
Monate der pandemiebewältigung benötigen
und schaffen müssen wir reagieren mit
den notwendigen und rechtssicheren
Maßnahmen auf die sehr schwierige
corona-lage
sie sehr geehrte Kolleginnen Kollegen
von der Union wollen allerdings an den
verfassungsrechtlich äußerst
problematischen Sonderrecht festhalten
das an die Feststellung der epidemischen
Lage nationaler Tragweite gebunden ist
sie wollen das sowohl
verfassungsrechtlich als auch
epidemiologisch fragwürdige
Ausgangssperren und beherbergungsverbote
oder die flächendeckenden Schließungen
von Einzelhandelsbetrieben beibehalten
werden auch maskendeals werden weiter
möglich ja wenn wenn sie politische
Verantwortung hätten aber die übernehmen
jetzt wir
wir erhalten
wir erhalten das hohe Schutzniveau dass
wir gegen covid 19 in Deutschland haben
nicht nur sondern wir erhöhen ist und
das ist auch dringend notwendig die
corona-situation in Deutschland ist
äußerst schwierig
65.000 Neuinfektionen volllaufende
Intensivstationen in manchen Regionen
müssen kobit 19 Patientinnen Patienten
verlegt werden in andere häuserplanpaare
Operationen werden abgesagt die
Belastung für das medizinische und
pflegerische Personal ist dramatisch und
genau deshalb weil die Lage so schwierig
ist brauchen die Länder Rechtssicherheit
bei der Anordnung ihrer Schutzmaßnahmen
und diese Rechtssicherheit schaffen wir
mit dem vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf und
ich sage hier noch mal sage hier nochmal
in aller Ausdrücklichkeit
in aller Ausdrücklichkeit die Länder
haben mit dem vorgelegten Gesetzentwurf
mehr Möglichkeiten des effizienten
Handelns als bei der aktuellen noch
gültigen Rechtslage die Länder werden
weiterhin
die Länder werden weiterhin bewährte
Instrumente zu Anwendung bringen 2G 3G
3G Plus kontaktbeschränkungen im
öffentlichen und privaten Bereich
personenobergrenzen Kontakt
Nachverfolgung wir schaffen mit den
Gesetz Rechtssicherheit für zwei g Plus
und wir geben den Ländern mit einer
Öffnungsklausel die Möglichkeit für
weitergehende Schutzmaßnahmen zwingende
Voraussetzung hier ist der Beschluss des
jeweiligen landesparlamentes damit
können
beispielsweise dann auch Veranstaltungen
abgesagt Diskotheken oder sonstige
Freizeiteinrichtungen vorübergehend
geschlossen werden und und wir
ermöglichen bundesweit einheitliche
Schutzmaßnahmen die weit über die
Möglichkeiten hinausgehen die die Länder
augenblicklich haben 3G am Arbeitsplatz
3G im öffentlichen Personen und
Fernverkehr besondere testpflichten für
sensible Einrichtungen Homeoffice und
gleichzeitig schaffen wir und sichern
wir ab dass das Gesundheitsamt bei
konkreten Ausbruchsgeschehen einzelne
Erschließungen anordnen kann um das
Infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen mit
diesem vorgelegten Gesetzentwurf sorgen
wir für Rechtssicherheit und schützen
die Menschen die am verletzlichsten sind
Liebe
liebe Bürgerinnen liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger vor uns stehen zweifelsohne
anstrengende Monate das ist frustrierend
und es könnte für uns alles so viel
einfacher sein einfacher wenn mehr
Bürgerinnen und Bürger geimpft werden
einfacher wenn wir mit den
Auffrischungsimpfungen weiter werden und
um vor die vierte Welle zu kommen müssen
wir täglich mindestens 1,4 Millionen
impfen Menschen impfen und das schaffen
wir das haben wir im Sommer schon
geschafft und wir brauchen jetzt wieder
einen gemeinsamen Kraft ab
niedergelassene Ärzte werden impfen wir
werden die Impfzentren hochfahren mobile
Teams zum Einsatz kommen die Devise
lautet impfen impfen impfen und mein
dringender Appell an die heutige
Konferenz der Ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentinnen sorgen Sie dafür
dass nicht nur Beschlussvorlagen
vorgelegt werden sondern dass diese dann
auch konkret umgesetzt und kontrolliert
werden
und abschließend und abschließend kann
ich Ihnen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der Union folgende Anmerkung nicht
ersparen ihr Antrag zu epidemischen Lage
ist fadenscheinig und durchsichtig sie
lassen sich von sie lassen sich von
ihren Freistaaten treiben die
Schlusslichter bei der Impfquote sind
und Spitzenreiter bei der Inzidenz die
ALF
die all die Maßnahmen die all die
Maßnahmen deren Wegfalls sie jetzt so
lautstark beklagen die flächendeckende
Schließung von Betrieben von Schulen von
Hotels längst hätten anordnen können es
aber nicht getan haben und selbst
und selbst
und selbst und selbst wenn sie erst
jetzt erst täten hätte die
Rechtsverordnung immer noch Gültigkeit
bis zum 15 Dezember wenn sie kommen Sie
bitte zum Schluss gerne
dein karierten klein klein denn wir
bringen ein ausgewogenes Gesetz zur
Abstimmung um gemeinsam Corona zu
überwinden und Corona kennt keine
Ländergrenzen und keine Parteigrenzen
ich bitte um Zustimmung
Sabine Dittmer hat hier für die SPD den
Gesetzentwurf noch einmal verteidigt und
die Union angegriffen für ihre Kritik
dass das ein oder andere Instrument aus
dem sogenannten Instrumentenkasten
gestrichen wurde wie zum Beispiel
Reiseverbote oder lockdown-maßnahmen
Design ja in der jetzigen Lage von
unionsregierten Ländern auch überhaupt
noch nicht ergriffen worden so ihre
Kritik Stefan starke jetzt sind der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu Fraktion
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren Frau Kollegin
Dittmar sie werden mit ihrer Rede und
mit dem was sie vorgelegt haben als
Gesetzesentwurf der Dramatik der Lage
nicht gerecht und
für Parteipolitik
besteht an dieser Stelle schon überhaupt
kein Anlass die Lage ist in diesem Land
hochdramatisch die vierte Welle hat
unser Land mit voller Wucht erfasst und
wir steuern tatsächlich auf einen sehr
schweren winterzug und die Zahl der
Neuinfektionen liegt aktuell bei über
65.000 die 7-tages-inzidenz bei 336
deutschlandweit gesehen
und unsere Krankenhäuser stoßen doch in
weiten Teilen schon an ihren Grenzen
Intensivbetten sind belegt es gibt einen
Engpass wir sehen schon in einzelnen
Regionen vor Dietmar Verlegungen von
Patientinnen und Patienten planbare
Operationen werden letztendlich
aufgehoben sie werden verschoben und
auch unsere Ärztinnen und Ärzte und sie
Pflegekräfte die unglaubliches in diesem
Land leisten stoßen an ihre
Belastungsgrenze das ist die gesamte
Lage vor der wir in diesem Bereich
stehen und es ist ganz überwiegend die
ungeimpften die sich auf den
Intensivbetten befinden und deswegen
bleibt richtig impfen ist der Weg aus
der Pandemie es macht den entscheidenden
Unterschied denn wer sich geimpft hat
der hat einen höheren Schutz vor einem
schweren Krankheitsverlauf der sich und
andere vor Ansteckung und deswegen ist
auch hier an meiner Stelle an dieser
Stelle hier noch mal mein Appell all
diejenigen die Zweifel haben die
unentschlossen sind bitte lassen Sie
sich impfen das schützt Sie und schützt
unsere Gesellschaft das ist jetzt
weiterhin notwendig
und diejenigen die bereits einen
Impfschutz haben kommt jetzt die dritte
Impfung das nimmt auch Fahrt auf 4,3
Millionen haben die Bitte Impfung
bekommen hier bleibt noch einiges zu tun
die Länder fahren hier die Impfzentren
hoch wir brauchen auch hier alle
kapazitätenmobile impfteams Heimärzte
Betriebsärzte
Hausärzte Betriebsärzte vieles mehr und
auch natürlich auch die Bürgerschaft
gezielt anzusprechen aber neben dem
impfenpunkt sind weitere Schutzmaßnahmen
erforderlich wir müssen die Zahl der
Neuinfektionen drastisch reduzieren
jetzt reduziert wir müssen die
infektionsdynamik reduzieren jetzt und
brechen und dazu trifft die Links gelbe
Koalition heute
hier im Bund ihre ersten politischen
Entscheidungen und heute machen sie ihre
ersten Fehler der erste Fehler ist sie
verlängern nicht die epidemische Lage
von nationaler Tragweite das haben sie
angekündigt der zweite Fehler sie
verkürzen den Maßnahmenkatalog der
Länder die Zahlen gehen hoch und sie
reduzieren die Maßnahmen das kann nicht
gut gehen
und der dritte Fehler
in dieser Situation brauchen wir eine
enge Abstimmung zwischen den Ländern und
dem Bund das hat die SPD das hat Scholz
hat die Ministerpräsident verhindert von
Seiten der SPD dass das stattfindet und
jetzt ist es zumindest gut dass heute
des Erfolgs aber es hätte viel früher
erfolgen müssen und das zeigt sie haben
keinen Plan für diese Pandemie und wie
man diesem entgegnen kann und wir
stellen heute den Antrag die epidemische
Lage zur verlängern weil sie flexible
weil sie die notwendigen passgenauen
Rahmen den Ländern an die Hand gibt und
es ist das falsche Signal dass sie an
die Bevölkerung aussenden dass sie genau
dieses bewährte Rechtsinstrument dass
wir haben dass sie dieses nicht
verlängern wollen ohne Not ohne Not in
diesem Bereich
und es ist auch inhaltlich falsch
es ist auch inhaltlich falsch dies zu
tun
sie machen ein neues Sonderrecht dass
sie neu setzen und es zeigt sich dass
sie sich in dem Bereich ja komplett
verrannt haben Marco Buschmann hat
gesagt wir geben den Ländern einen
kleinen Katalog mit wenig
eingriffsintensiven Maßnahmen an die
Hand um sicher und verantwortungsvoll
durch den Winter zu kommen
tatsbegrenzung doch wieder
länderöffnungsklausel doch wieder über
die Begrenzung hinausgehen wo sie gesagt
haben sie schaffen einen Übergangsrecht
das letztendlich begrenzt ist das alles
haben sie sich komplett verrannt und sie
haben das letztendlich hier verändert
aber nicht in dem Maße dass es genügen
kann für das was vor uns steht die
Länder brauchen einen wirklich
passgenauen flexiblen Rahmen diesen
verkürzen sie ohne Not das ist der
falsche Weg für Deutschland
Stefan starke neue Bundestag gleich
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
für den Bereich Gesundheit der hat noch
mal dargestellt die Union wird einen
eigenen Antrag einbringen Verlängerung
der epidemischen Lage und diese Antrag
der Ampel so sagt er wer springt zu kurz
und deswegen wird die cdu/csu diesen
Antrag nichts mittragen jetzt Kathrin
Göring-Eckardt die Fraktionsvorsitzende
der bündnisgründen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen eine sehr berühmte deutsche
Bundeskanzlerin hat mal gesagt mit dem
Kopf durch die Wand wird nicht gehen es
liegt zum Schluss immer die Wand und es
wäre schon hilfreich
es wäre schon hilfreich
die Wand zu sehen
es wäre schon hilfreich die Wand zu
sehen die sie nicht nicht nur nicht
eingerissen haben sondern
muss ja nicht mal verstanden haben wo
die Tür ist meine Damen und Herren das
was gerade in unserem Land passiert in
den Krankenhäusern insbesondere ist
dramatisch und es wird noch dramatischer
werden denn die Infektionen können wir
nicht zurückdrehen das werden sich
weiter Menschen anstecken werden
erkranken und viele schwer mir macht das
riesige Sorgen und ich sage sehr klar
und bewusst wir befinden uns in einer
Notsituation die Krankenhäuser ganz
besonders und darauf müssen wir
reagieren und zwar jetzt und zwar
konsequent und zwar gemeinsam Bund
Länder Kommunen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und das ist das was wir heute hier in
diesem Parlament besprechen so wie es in
der Demokratie gut und üblich ist
natürlich
natürlich könnte ich mich jetzt hier
hinstellen und sagen was alles nicht
getan wurde und gar nicht erst in diese
Situation zu kommen Herr Stracke denn
die Rechtslage die sie hier einklagen
besteht ja ich könnte fragen seit wie
vielen Wochen und Monaten hatten
eigentlich das corona-kabinett nicht
getagt ich könnte fragen
wo es eigentlich
wo ist eigentlich der große Plan zum
Booster den man spätestens zu Beginn des
Septembers hätte besprechen müssen vom
Bund aus mit den Ländern
ich könnte fragen warum gibt es
eigentlich nicht viel mehr und längst
flächendeckend 2G oder auch von mir aus
regionale lockdowns
gefunden haben aber
aber heute
meine Damen und Herren an diesem Tag
erwarten die Menschen in unserem Land zu
Recht dass wir uns hier zusammenreißen
und Handeln es interessiert nämlich
niemanden kein Intensivmediziner und
keine intensivmedizinerin und noch nicht
mal den ungeimpften im Beatmungsgerät ob
hier die einen Opposition üben und die
anderen sich anschicken Regierung zu
machen es interessiert niemanden dass
wir in einer Zwischenzeit sind sondern
die einzige Möglichkeit die wir hier als
Parlament gemeinsam haben ist
tatsächlich zu handeln und Verantwortung
zu übernehmen und das erwarte ich auch
von Ihnen meine Damen und Herren
und ich erwarte das übrigens auch ich
erwarte das übrigens auch bei den
Gesprächen mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und dem Bundesrat
und eins nervt mich wirklich wer die
Notsituation in der wir jetzt gerade
sind gleichsetzt mit dem rechtlichen
Konstrukt der epidemischen Lage verkennt
worum es geht denn wir sind nicht
wir sind nicht in Jahren Null der
Pandemie wir sind im zweiten Jahr und
wir wählen ein Verfahren das alles in
sich hat was es jetzt braucht Parlament
Debatte Anhörung von Expertinnen und
Experten und wieder Debatte und
Beschluss und dann Bundesrat meine Damen
und Herren das ist das was wir machen
und das ist übrigens auch der
Unterschied zwischen Ihnen und uns dass
wir sagen diese Parlamentsdebatte ist
das A und O nicht nur hier die Hand
heben und sagen wir haben eine
epidemische Notlage sondern auch
tatsächlich sich
setzen um welche Maßnahmen es geht und
welche wirksam sind und er bring
t auch kaputt heute
wir brauchen rechtssichere Maßnahmen bei
zwei Drittel von geimpften kann man eben
nicht handeln wie in einer Zeit als der
Impfstoff noch nicht mal richtig für die
über 70-Jährigen reichte und Corona
verschwindet doch nicht wenn Sie jetzt
hier die epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite beschließen Corona bekämpfen
wir durch Maßnahmen und durch impfen und
ich verlange von ihnen dass sie sich dem
stellen welche Maßnahmen und wie
schaffen wir es mit dem Impfen das ist
die Aufgabe in vielerlei Hinsicht vor
der wir alle gemeinsam stehen und
hoffentlich auch die Länder
und das Paket das Paket Frau Dittmer hat
zu Recht darauf hingewiesen ist deutlich
mehr als wir bisher hatten Homeoffice
oder 3G damit schützen wir die
Arbeitsplätze wir schützen den
öffentlichen Verkehr mit 3G in den Zügen
und natürlich ist es kontrollierbar mit
Stichproben wie man das eben macht in
solchen Fällen wir
ermöglichen vieles weitere in den
Ländern Masken in Schulen das sollte
selbstverständlich sein und wenn man
Karneval feiern will einerseits und sagt
das war schon ganz prima und übermorgen
sagt wir haben aber eine riesige Notlage
dann ist das für mich jedenfalls nicht
glaubwürdig aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
meine Damen und Herren
ist es möglich
ist wirklich überall Auflagen
auszusprechen es ist möglich
Veranstaltungen auch abzusagen sie
können jetzt sehr drastische Maßnahmen
ergreifen auch in Sachsen auch in Bayern
wir sind auf sie zugegangen und haben
gesagt solche Maßnahmen haben einen
längeren Übergang das haben wir auch
ihre Bitte hin im Hauptausschuss
beschlossen bis über den dritten Advent
hinaus dann muss es aber jetzt auch
gemacht werden meine Damen und Herren
bitte und zwar jetzt
wir brauchen
wir brauchen einen Schutzwall wir
brauchen einen Schutz weil im
öffentlichen Leben und besonders dort wo
es um die Kinder und Jugendlichen geht
und deswegen steht zum ersten Mal in
diesem Gesetz dass wir die Pflicht haben
zur Berücksichtigung der Situation von
Kindern und Jugendlichen die Pflicht das
heißt jede Maßnahme muss in Zukunft
daraufhin überprüft werden wie werden
Kinder geschützt gegen Corona und wie
soll man dafür dass Schulen und Kitas so
lange wie möglich aufbleiben meine Damen
und Herren ja
es ist so
es ist so dass wir in einer wahnsinnig
schwierigen Situation sind und es geht
hier um Gefahrenabwehr und es geht nicht
ohne impfen und ich hoffe sehr dass der
Plan zum Impfen bei den Ländern sehr
bald vorgelegt wird dass wir als Bund
alles dafür tun dass überall geimpft wo
es nur geht von den Apotheken angefangen
bis hin zu den mobilen impfteams von
ihnen verlange ich Herr Brinkhaus Herr
Dobrindt ihre gesamte Fraktion sie
trauen sich noch nicht mal hierher ans
Pult heute von ihnen verlange ich mit
Verantwortung zu übernehmen ich lade Sie
ein ich lade die Länder ein und ich
hoffe sehr dass wir in diesem Land
zeigen wir können gemeinsam in einer
schwierigen Situation Verantwortung
übernehmen und es stiehlt sich niemand
weg wenn es dann wirklich unbequem wird
herzlichen Dank
noch mal einen wichtigen Punkt
angesprochen die rechtliche
Dimensionen nämlich die Feststellung der
epidemischen Lage von nationaler
Tragweite vor ein dreivierteljahren
bedeutete dass der Gesundheitsminister
quasi festlegen konnte wie es weitergeht
das Parlament konnte sich da nicht mehr
einrichten hat die quasi die
gesetzgebungs abgegeben an den
Gesundheitsminister der über Verordnung
regieren konnte das will man mit diesem
Gesetz zurückholen jetzt Marco Buschmann
für die FDP wir legen Ihnen heute ein
neues Maßnahmenpaket zur Bekämpfung von
Corona vor dieses neue Maßnahmenpaket
tritt an die Stelle eines alten
Maßnahmenpaketes dieses diesem alten
Maßnahmenpaket hätte man
unterschiedliche Namen geben können es
trägt nun mal den Namen der epidemischen
Notlage das hat aber nichts mit der
Beschreibung der Wirklichkeit zu tun ein
Maßnahmenpaket bewertet man an den
Rechtsfolgen und den Instrumenten die es
enthält und wenn einige hier den den
Druck erwecken mit der Auswechslung des
Maßnahmenpakets sei die Botschaft
verbunden Corona sei vorbei den will ich
hier ein für alle Mal noch mal klar
sagen was wir auch schon vermehren
Wochen gesagt haben Corona ist nicht
vorbei und war nicht vorbei Corona war
immer gefährlich und es war immer unsere
gemeinsame Haltung diese Gefahr
entschlossen zu bekämpfen behaupten sie
nicht das Gegenteil liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der cdu/csu
die Lage ist ernst insbesondere dort wo
die Impfquoten niedrig sind wo die
boosterquoten niedrig sind und das ist
schwerpunktmäßig nennen wir es mal bei
Namen insbesondere in Sachsen und Bayern
der Fall das ist insbesondere in Sachsen
und Bayern der Fall und deshalb kann man
nur alle Menschen in diesem Land
auffordern weil wir es sehen dass das
Impfen hilft wenn sie noch nicht geimpft
sind lassen sie sich einen Impftermin
geben wenn sie sich Boostern lassen
können lassen sie sich Boostern und ich
kann nur alle Verantwortungsträger in
diesem Land auffordern tun wir alles
dafür dass alle Personen die medizinisch
verantwortbar eine Spritze setzen können
sich an einer nationalen impfoffensive
beteiligen das ist der Weg aus der
Pandemie meine Damen und Herren
die Behauptung dass das neue
Maßnahmenpaket die Länder wehrlos da
lassen ist die objektiv falsch sie war
es schon von Anfang an weil wir sehr
robuste Maßnahmen von Anfang an auf
rechtssichere Beine gestellt haben auch
die praktisch relevanten Maßnahmen wie
beispielsweise 2G oder 3G oder die
Hygienekonzepte mit personenübergrenzen
standen vorher auf rechtlich Töne an den
Füßen wir stellen Sie jetzt auf
rechtssichere Füße und es ist ein
Fortschritt in der pandemiebekämpfung
meine Damen und Herren
wir haben den Maßnahmenpaket erweitert
und mittlerweile geht es sogar bis zu
kontaktbeschränkungen im öffentlichen
und im privaten Raum wer der Meinung ist
dass das kein scharfes Schwert gegen die
Pandemie sei der war es sich nicht wie
man ihm helfen kann wir haben effektive
Maßnahmen um Corona zu bekämpfen
behaupten sie nicht das Gegenteil dass
es wahrheitswidrig meine Damen und
Herren
trotzdem hört und liest man ja immer
wieder es reiche nicht wir würden ja den
Instrumentenkasten reduzieren und das
sei ein Fehler Herr Stracke hat es ja
wieder gesagt das sagen sie immer
abstrakt und dann gehen wir doch mal
rein welche Maßnahmen meinen Sie denn
immer dann wenn wir mit Ihnen über die
konkreten Maßnahmen sprechen wollen
geben Sie uns ja recht
sie geben uns recht wollen sie
verfassungswidrige Ausgang sperren Helge
braun sagt nein
wollen sie den Handel den
einzelhandelpauschal schließen Armin
Laschet hat gestern beim Handelsverband
Deutschland erklärt der Handel ist kein
pandemietreiber und recht hat er damit
also wollen sie ihn doch wohl offenbar
nicht pauschal zu machen
wollen sie
bundesweitpauschale lockdowns mit
Schulschließungen und
hochschulschließungen Hendrik wüst hat
vor wenigen Tagen im Landtag
Nordrhein-Westfalen erklärt das sei eine
Bestrafung der bereits geimpften
Personen die sich solidarisch gezeigt
haben sie geben uns auch da recht meine
Damen und Herren
und deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union ich könnte so
weitermachen in Wahrheit in der Sache
haben sie keine Argumente die ihren
abstrakten Vorwurf der
instrumentenkastenzeit zu wenig belegen
könnte in Wahrheit kämpfen sie auch
nicht in der Sache gegen Corona sie
kämpfen gegen eine politische
Konstellation die im Werden begriffen
ist wir sollten aber heute nicht Union
gegen ampelstellen es geht heute nicht
um Union oder Ampel es geht darum unser
Land zu schützen und dafür stellen wir
die richtigen Maßnahmen zur Verfügung
meine Damen und Herren
Marco Buschmann der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer ist ja
noch der
[Applaus]
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion hier mit viel
Applaus bedacht zumal er seinerseits die
Union attackierte mit mehreren Fragen
aufzeigte dass innerhalb der Union auch
sehr große Meinungsunterschiede zu den
verschiedenen Maßnahmen Herr stinokrupp
Balla jetzt der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
AFD frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren vor drei Monaten appellierte
ich in der Debatte um die epidemische
Lage an dieses Hohe Haus das Zitat
Bürger die sich nicht impfen lassen
keine impfverweigerer sind sie nehmen
ihr gegebenes Grundrecht in Anspruch
selbst über ihre Gesundheit und damit
ihr Leben zu entscheiden eine
Impfentscheidung muss die individuelle
Entscheidung eines jeden Bürgers bleiben
Zitat Ende
heute verhandeln wir die nächste
Änderung des vielschichtigen
Infektionsschutzgesetzes diesmal von der
voraussichtlich neuen Koalitionsparteien
eingebracht aber wo sind eigentlich ihre
Wahlversprechen an die Bürger geblieben
weg von der Politik der Verbote und für
ein Ende der völlig überzogenen
Maßnahmen ist ein Spruch der FDP liebe
FDP wo ist der Wahlspruch geblieben die
ampelparteien machen anscheinend mit der
panischen Politik der letzten zwei Jahre
nahtlos weiter und Herr Linda sie haben
ja sogar gestern eine Impfpflicht nicht
mehr ausgeschlossen und da sieht man
eigentlich sie sind noch nicht mal in
der Regierung und schon das erste mal
umgekippt Respekt meine Damen und Herren
nun können wohl alle Bürger auch davon
ausgehen dass sie von der alten und
neuen Bundesregierung sich vollends vom
Grundgesetz abgewendet haben und die
faktische Impfpflicht durch das
Parlament Peitschen wollen seit zwei
Jahren Spalten die Regierenden in der
Herzkammer der Demokratie wie sie dieses
Haus ja so gerne nennen aktiv unsere
Gesellschaft sie haben das Feindbild der
ungeimpften zu eigen gemacht und diese
sollen für alles verantwortlich sein wie
überfüllte Krankenhäuser und steigende
Infektionsraten aber ist es nicht
verwunderlich dass es nach einem Jahr
und einer Impfquote von nahezu 70
Prozent keine Entspannung im
Gesundheitswesen gibt oder liegt es
nicht doch an den politischen
Versäumnissen der alten Bundesregierung
es wurden im vergangenen Jahr
Krankenhäuser geschlossen mehr als 4000
Intensivbetten abgebaut in Sachsen
nahezu 300 und es hat sich noch immer
niemand um personellen Nachwuchs im
Pflegebereich bemüht daran warum haben
sie 4000 Betten abgebaut antworten Sie
auf diese Fragen und genau das und genau
das alles sind Rahmenbedingungen um die
wir uns hier zu kümmern haben liebe
Kollegen dafür können wir nicht die
Verantwortung an ungeimpfte Bürger
abgeben und diese endgültig zu
sündenbecken machen und meine Damen und
Herren ich weiß sie sprechen jetzt
wieder von einer neuen und viel
schlimmeren Situation in der vierten
Welle aber machen Sie sich doch bitte
bei den Bürgern endlich mal ehrlich und
geben sie zu dass sie sich mit ihren
Maßnahmen und Empfehlungen verkalkuliert
haben fast religiös rufen Sie die
Gesellschaft zur Impfung auf bekommen
Sie aber mit dass die Menschen da
draußen dem nicht uneingeschränkt folgen
möchten und ich denke sie alle hier
haben verstanden dass die Hoffnung die
sie in die Impfstoffe gesetzt haben zu
groß war das RKI berichtet mittlerweile
von 175.000 impfdurchbrüchen und
wahrscheinlich sie Dunkelziffer noch
viel höher das heißt die angeboten den
Punkt sind nicht so zuverlässig und
dauerhaft wie anfänglich erhofft und ja
niemand konnte das wissen nur was ist
die Perspektive die sie den Bürgern
aufzeigen pusterimpfung im halbjahrstag
oder einmal im Quartal oder vielleicht
eine abo-impfung was aber ist
beispielsweise mit der Weiterentwicklung
von wirksamen Medikamenten
über eine Sache sind wir uns jedoch
einig jede Person unabhängig vom
sogenannten gehstatus kann über Träger
des Viruses sein und aus dieser
Erkenntnis heraus sind die 2G oder drei
geregelung abzulegen und eigentlich
sinnlos sie sind mindestens ein Lockdown
auf Raten und sollen die Bürger immer
stärker unter Druck setzen sich impfen
zu lassen Werte Kollegen wer als
Politiker mit solchen Mitteln gegen das
eigene Volk kämpft überschreitet maßlos
die eigenen Kompetenzen und beugt wieder
unser Grundgesetz
hören Sie endlich auf einzelne Gruppen
gegeneinander auszuspielen sie
erschüttern damit das Vertrauen in
unsere parlamentarische Demokratie immer
stärker es liegt in unserer Hand ob die
übermächtigkeit des Staates heute ein
Ende findet die Bürger haben ein Recht
darauf eigenverantwortlich handeln zu
dürfen vielen Dank
und da sehen wir sie noch zurückkommen
Angela Merkel und Olaf Scholz hatten
sich eben zu einem kurzen Plausch
zurückgezogen ab 13 Uhr empfängt die
Bundeskanzlerin gemeinsam mit Olaf
Scholz die Ministerpräsidenten im
Kanzleramt auch da geht es dann um die
Frage wie geht es weiter im Kampf gegen
die Pandemie Redner hier im Bundestag
jetzt Dietmar Bartsch der Fraktionschef
der linksfraktionen
offensichtlich ändert das Coronavirus
seine Gefährlichkeit in abhängig davon
wer regiert oder wer regieren will aber
daran erinnern am 11 juni lag die
bundesweite Inzidenz bei 19 damals hat
die SPD für die vergängerverlängerung
der epidemischen Lage gestimmt und am
Firmung und die Grünen übrigens auch am
25 August lag die Inzidenz bei 61 und es
waren ganz viele geimpft und sie haben
auch für die Verlängerung gestimmt jetzt
sind dieser Woche liegt die Inzidenz bei
über 300 und sie sagen wir sind für die
Beendigung der epidemischen Lage ich
kann nur sagen
Christian Linder was haben Sie
eigentlich den Grünen und der SPD in den
Tee getan bei den
Koalitionsverhandlungen weil die
Richtlinie Kompetenz liegt ja jetzt
offensichtlich bei Ihnen
und was auch ganz klar zu sagen in
Richtung Union natürlich brauchen wir
Regelungen und jetzt diese
geisterfahrerei wir blockieren das im
Bundesrat das ist unverantwortlich eine
rechtssichere Grundlage für den Schutz
der Bevölkerung ist dringend notwendig
meine Herren
Entschuldigung erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage von Frau Dittmar ich
erlaube selbstverständlich gerne jede
Zwischenfrage Frau
die Zwischenfrage zulassen ich möchte
einfach nur noch mal möchten sie fragen
ob sie zu Kenntnis genommen haben dass
damals im August als die epidemische
Lage erneut verlängert wurde dass auch
von meiner Fraktion immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen wurde das wird die natürlich
verlängern müssen weil der rechtsra
hmen Geländer
s Gesetze so wie wir sie jetzt vorlegen
indem wir die Maßnahmen definieren die
sie rechtssicher dann zur Anwendung
bringen können dass das zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt nicht möglich war zu
verhandeln und deshalb die Lage
verlängert werden muss weil die Länder
recht sicher ihre Maßnahmen die
Anwendung bringen müssen
Überzeugung ist dann frage ich mich
wieso haben Sie sich denn damals dafür
nicht eingesetzt ich habe ja darauf
hingewiesen wie Gefährlichkeit ist in
Abhängigkeit wer regiert jetzt stellen
sie die Kanzlerschaft auf einmal
verändern Sie das alle im alles im Sinne
von Christian Linder das kann man ja
machen aber dann bitte etwas
Selbstkritik sie haben hier die letzten
vier Jahre Verantwortung getragen und
sind für diese Situation
mitverantwortlich stehen sie sich da
nicht rausmachen liebe Freunde
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die wurde
jetzt viel von Glaubwürdigkeit und von
Stringenz in den Maßnahmen gesprochen
Katrin Göring Eckert hat darauf
hingewiesen und ich will da gerne darauf
eingehen also es sind natürlich nicht
Worte aber wer am Montag früh eine
Impfpflicht raus posaun und das am
Nachmittag wieder einsammeln muss
das ist so bleiben so geht das genau
nicht meine Damen und Herren Herr
Bartsch ja Entschuldigung erlauben sie
noch eine Zwischenfrage von Frau Dr
Rottmann da ich ja angekündigt habe zu
jedem gerne selbstverständlich
dr Bartsch vielen Dank sie haben sich
mühsam einen schönen Einstieg für ihre
Rede überlegte basiert aber auf einer
unwahren Behauptung nämlich dass wir im
Sommer der epidemische Verlängerung der
epidemischen Lage zugestimmt hätten
ich darf ich darf sie korrigieren sie
können gerne das redeprotokoll sich
anschauen ich habe gesagt dass im Juni
die Inzidenz bei 19 lag am 11 juni und
da haben Sie zugestimmt im August hat
nur die SPD zugestimmt schauen Sie nach
in das Protokoll schlicht die Wahrheit
was ich gesagt habe aber danke dass ich
das noch mal wiederholen kann
Wiederholung ist die Mutter der Weisheit
meine Damen und Herren nach fast zwei
Jahren Pandemie haben viele Bürgerinnen
und Bürger es satt Sprüche zu hören wo
die Halbwertszeit nicht mal die
Mittagspause übersteht das untergräbt
die Akzeptanz hier ist mehrfach gesagt
worden ich will voll einverstanden nicht
reden sondern handeln da ist in den
letzten Monaten eben viel zu wenig
passiert und da gab es auch
verantwortlich es gibt eine
Bundesregierung im März die letzte
bundländerrunde corona-kabinett nein die
Bundesregierung hat sich in den
Sommerschlaf begeben das ist die
Wahrheit und deshalb klar und eindeutig
das was sie da entschieden haben Tests
wurden kostenpflichtig was für eine
dramatische Fehlentscheidung Luftfilter
in den Schulen immer noch Mangelware und
niedrigschwellige impfangebote ja wo ist
denn das und wir reden darüber jetzt
muss endlich geschehen schauen Sie mal
nach Bremen die haben das im übrigen
ziemlich gut hingekriegt oder warum
verpflichten wir nicht zum Beispiel die
Krankenkassen jeden Versicherten
anzuschreiben und belohnen dann auch das
Impfen meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen viele
Pflegekräfte haben den Beruf verlassen
Intensivbetten sind leer mit jeder
corona-welle wird unser
Gesundheitssystem schwächer
4.000 Intensivbetten weniger seit Beginn
des Jahres was für eine desaströse
Bilanz und Herr Stracke beklagt das und
fragt sich warum ein Grund ein Grund
will ich zumindest nennen das
Statistische Bundesamt hat neue Zahlen
vorgelegt zwischen dem zweiten Quartal
1919 und im zweiten Quartal 2021 hat
sich der Lohn des Pflegepersonals in den
Kliniken um sage und schreibe
1,50€ erhöht brutto und in der
Altenpflege sogar nur um ein Euro 31 in
der Stunde meine Damen und Herren
kein Wunder dass die Leute gehen das ist
respektlos gegenüber denjenigen die uns
seit zwei Jahren über Wasser halten
meine Damen und ist das eigentlich das
Ergebnis des pflegepacks der
Bundesregierung mein meine Damen und
Herren im letzten Jahr wurden
Krankenhäuser geschlossen 20 allein in
diesem Jahr Deutschland hat aber nicht
zu wenige Krankenhäuser wir brauchen ein
schließungsmoratorium da erwarte ich von
der Ampel dass sie wirklich das Klinik
sterben stoppen meine Damen und Herren
und über die sozialen Schäden die
anstehen warum warum bei Gastronomen
Geschäften und uns jetzt brauchen wir
dort Maßnahmen die dringend ergriffen
werden müssen das wäre notwendig damit
es nicht wieder ein Desaster wie mit den
letzten novemberhilfen gibt vor allem
aber eins wer ankündigt der muss auch
liefern weil sonst gilt hier das Prinzip
Söder nicht 2G nicht 3G sondern GK große
Klappe meine Damen und Herren
deutschland braucht aber endlich eine
stringente corona-politik und da erwarte
ich von den ampelparteien dass da
endlich etwas Konkretes vorgelegt wird
herzlichen Dank
heute gut aufgelegt allerdings das Frau
göring-eckhart Herrn Spahn vielleicht
behaben könnte das scheint unrealistisch
der hat jedenfalls auch die Union davor
gewarnt dieses Gesetz im Bundesrat zu
blockieren mal sehen wie die Linken
nachher hier im Bundestag Abstimmung
Johannes Fechner jetzt ähm für die SPD
steigen dramatisch es gibt leider immer
mehr Tote dass Pflegepersonal ist an der
Belastungsgrenze und das können wir
nicht hinnehmen wir schaffen schärfere
Maßnahmen in diesem Gesetz liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und Herr
Kollege Bartsch ich fand ihre Rede sehr
dünn kann rahmenlos überzeugt sie
offensichtlich nicht denn ihre Argumente
er hat nämlich allem zugestimmt im
Bundesrat und er wird auch morgen
unseren Gesetz zustimmen also insofern
ist es unglaubwürdig wenn sie nicht mal
ihre eigene Leute überzeugen können mit
ihrer Argumenten richtig ist
wir lassen die Rechtsfigur der
epidemischen Lage Auslaufen weil wir
nicht mehr diese schwierige
rechtskonstrukt haben wollen wir wollen
nicht mehr diese weitreichenden
Befugnisse für die Bundesregierung und
wir wollen auch nicht Dinge die sich von
vielen Gerichten auch gekippt wurden wir
wollen keine Ausgangssperren mehr wir
wollen keine pauschalen
Grundrechtseingriffe wie
Schulschließungen und deswegen lassen
wir dieses rechtskonstrukt auslaufen und
zu recht sagen Ministerpräsidenten aus
der Union wie Herr Günther auch wie Herr
Spahn noch vor kurzem und auch viele wie
viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
Union dass wir diese Rechtsfigur nicht
mehr brauchen und deswegen beenden wir
heute diese epidemische Lage liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und falsch ist
der Vorwurf dass wir nicht handeln
würden dass wir den Instrumentenkasten
beschneiden würden das Gegenteil ist der
Fall wir schaffen eine 3d-pflicht für
den Arbeitsplatz das ist eine
weitreichende Maßnahme weil jetzt jeder
der eine ungeimpft ist und sich nicht
testen lässt Lohneinbußen riskiert und
wir schaffen die Regelung die gleiche
Regelung auch für Busse und Bahnen jeder
der ungeimpft jetzt Bahn fährt und kein
Test dabei hat der wird aus der Bahn
geworfen und dem droht auch noch ein
saftiges Bußgeld das sind massive
Maßnahmen die wir heute hier einführen
wollen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und auch den Bundesländern geben wir
weitreichende Handlungsmöglichkeiten sie
können abstandsgebote Regeln
kontaktbeschränkungen für ungeimpfte
maskenpflicht 2G oder zwei G +
Regelungen sie können Veranstaltungen
auf Personenzahlen beschränken und Sie
können Einrichtungen Auflagen machen
also kurzum mit diesem Gesetz können die
Bundesländer Schafe und hartmaß harte
Maßnahmen beschließen zum Schutz unserer
Bevölkerung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Entschuldigung erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
-regelungen mit der heutigen
gerichtslage schaffen können aber gerade
in Sachsen und auch in Bayern haben wir
führungsschwache Ministerpräsidenten die
sich lieber hinter dem Bund verstecken
als selbstbewusst die wichtigen
Maßnahmen zu treffen die für die
Bevölkerung erforderlich sind liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und was
wollen Sie denn was nicht heute schon
möglich wäre nach der heutigen
Rechtslage wo liegen wir denn wirklich
noch auseinander das allermeiste was
auch sie fordern steht in unserem Gesetz
wo liegen wir noch auseinander sie
wollen flächendeckend Schulen schließen
obwohl unsere Kinder doch so erheblich
gelitten haben sie wollen flächendeckend
Betriebe schließen können wohl dass die
massiven negativen Auswirkungen hatte
sie wollen weiter Ausgangssperren obwohl
das Gerichte gekippt haben und ganz
bemerkenswert finde ich für eine
christliche Partei sie wollen es
ermöglichen in der Adventszeit und in
der Weihnachtszeit Gottesdienste zu
verbieten also wohlgemerkt nicht mit
zwei g-regelungen zuzulassen sondern die
Möglichkeit das zu verbieten und das
machen wir auf keinen Fall mit denn wir
müssen bei allen Schutzmaßnahmen darauf
achten dass die Schutzmaßnahmen nicht
mehr negative Auswirkungen haben als wir
als sie nutzen und deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir flächendeckende
Schulschließungen und
Betriebsschließungen untersagen dass es
keine Ausgangssperren mehr geben wird
und das an Weihnachten und mit
Adventszeit Gottesdienste mit
Hygienekonzepte stattfinden können liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und leider mussten wir in der
Vergangenheit auch immer wieder erleben
dass Tests und impfnachweise gefälscht
wurden und weil das immer ein hohes
Risiko ist wenn ein ungeimpfter
möglicherweise infizierter also nicht
getesteter sich in Gesellschaft mit
anderen Bürgern begibt Veranstaltungen
besucht deswegen werden wir jetzt jeden
Fall von Fälschungen von impfausweisen
oder Tests unter Strafe stellen auch das
eine ganz wichtige Maßnahme und zum
Schluss lässt der Satz ich fand es immer
gut dass auch die Union sich hier bemüht
hat für diese wichtigen Maßnahmen zum
Schutz der Bevölkerung einen breiten
Konsens hier im Parlament herzustellen
diesen drohen sie heute zur verlassen
ich kann nur appellieren stimmen sie im
Bundesrat stimmen Sie hier im Bundestag
diesen wichtigen Verschärfungen zum
Schutz der Bevölkerung zu es geht hier
um tausende Menschenleben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Appell von Johannes Fechner die
Ampel hat das Gesetz was sie hier vor
einer Woche eingebracht hat noch mal
massiv nachgebessert 3g-2-regelung und
die Fraktion herr Klein Richter aus der
afd-fraktion mit einer Kurzintervention
in der Frau Präsidentin Kollege Dr
Fechner ich habe eine ganz praktische
Frage zu ihrer Ehren Ausführungen gerade
und zwar haben sie sich ja berühmt das
ungeimpfte Personen aus der Bahn
geworfen werden und zugleich sagten sie
dass die Schutzmaßnahmen keine
negativeren Auswirkungen haben dürften
als sie nutzen ich vertrete einen
Wahlkreis der sehr ländlich strukturiert
ist da gibt es viele kleine Dörfer da
gibt es relativ wenige Busse und es gibt
ganz bestimmt nicht in jedem Dorf ein
Testzentrum und ich habe eine ganz
praktische Frage wie soll das Menschen
machen die am Montagmorgen mit Bus oder
Bahn sie wollen doch klimafreundlich
sein zur Arbeit wollen zum Arzt wollen
zum einkaufen wollen
und Bus und Bahn ÖPNV nicht benutzen
können weil sie ja getestet sein müssen
was sie aber nicht sein können in ihrem
Ort und weil sie durch ihre Gesetzgebung
durch ihre verordnungsgebung auch das
eigene Zertifikat nicht anerkennen ich
frage sie deutlicher dr Fechner wie
sollen das die Leute machen oder wollen
Sie die zu Hause einsperren und sind sie
ernsthafter Meinung dass das
herauswerfen ungeimpfter aus der Bahn
und aus dem Bus keine negativeren
Auswirkungen hat als diese potenzielle
Schutzmaßnahme tatsächlich nützt
Herr Dr Fechner möchten Sie antworten
ja gerne also zunächst mal ist ein
Fortschritt dass die Corona
offensichtlich als Gefahr ansehen das
war in der afd-fraktion ja nicht immer
der Fall
und zum zweiten sind jetzt in der Tat
Länder gefragt überall Testangebote zu
machen und das wird auch kommen und der
einfache Rat ist lassen sie sich impfen
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger wie wäre es
wenn sie dafür eine Werbeveranstaltung
in ihrem Wahlkreis machen Herr Kollege
ja und ich wollte gerade noch ausführen
dass Herr Fechner also an die Union
appelliert hat dieses Gesetz vor allem
im Bundesrat nicht aufzuhalten es ist ja
verändert worden auch auf Interventionen
der Unionsfraktion haben sich die
ampelfraktionen bewegt und dennoch ist
der Widerstand bei der cdu/csu extrem
groß Thorsten frei jetzt der stellvert
eine Fraktionsvorsitzende liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich will ganz
ehrlich sein die Debatte verwirrt mich
genauso wie die Debatte die wir am
vergangenen Dienstag im Hauptausschuss
hatten wenn ich den ampelfraktionen
zuhöre dann höre ich bei den Grünen
liebe Frau Göring-Eckardt wir
verschärfen die Maßnahmen wir machen
alles besser wir machen mehr wir machen
das passgenaue wenn ich dem Herrn
Buschmann zuhöre dann sagt er das
gleiche wie am 27 Oktober wir
beschränkten die Maßnahmen auf das
absolut notwendige Maß keine so
einschneidenden Maßnahmen mehr
geringfügige Einschränkungen und der
mehr und die SPD ist wie immer in
between meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren das ist keine
Handlungsorientierung für die Zukunft so
bekämpfen wir diese Pandemie nicht und
ich will es noch mal ganz deutlich sagen
der Ausgangspunkt des Problems dass wir
heute diskutieren ist das 27 Oktober und
ich werfe Ihnen das ehrlich gesagt noch
nicht einmal vor in den letzten drei
Wochen haben wir eine unglaubliche
Dynamik in dieser Pandemie erlebt wie
nie zuvor seit dem März 2020 der Kollege
Stracke hat es gesagt im Bereich der
Inzidenz der Neuinfektionen der
hospitalisierungsrate der Auslastung der
Intensivbetten und vieles andere mehr
nur jemand hat vorher mal eine Wand und
eine berühmte Bundeskanzlerin zitiert
wenn Sie die sehen oder wenn Sie sehen
dass sie in eine falsche Richtung
gelaufen sind dann drehen Sie doch bitte
um anstatt dass sie weiter laufen
verkehrte Richtung oder sich an der Wand
eine blutige Nase holen das ist
unverantwortlich und zwar nicht nur
politisch es ist unverantwortlich
gegenüber den Menschen in unserem Land
für deren Schutz und für deren
Gesundheit wir verantwortlich sind und
deswegen stört es mich schon wenn Sie
hier eine Debatte führen die nach hinten
gerichtet ist die Verantwortung
abschiebt und die uns versucht
dazu zu bringen etwas zuzustimmen was
falsch ist im übrigen dass das
ausgerechnet von den Liberalen kommt des
irritiert mich schon sie verlangen hier
den Schulterschluss obwohl sie in den
vergangenen anderthalb Jahren gegen
alles gestimmt haben was hier zum
Gesundheitsschutz im Deutschen Bundestag
verabschiedet worden ist das ist ein
Scheinheiligkeit nicht zu überbieten und
es lassen wir Ihnen auch nicht
durchgehen
wir haben uns wegen des Ernstes Lages
der Lage sehr intensiv mit ihrem
Gesetzentwurf beschäftigt und wir hätten
ihn wir hätten diesem Gesetzentwurf auch
zugestimmt heute wenn Sie gleichzeitig
die epidemische Lage nationaler
Tragweite verlängert hätten denn beides
ist notwendig es ist zwingende
Voraussetzung dafür dass wir die
Epidemie bekämpfen können und im übrigen
das sagen doch nicht nur wir das sagen
doch insbesondere die
Ministerpräsidenten und zwar nicht nur
die Mehrheit der Ministerpräsidenten
nicht nur die
cdu/csu-ministerpräsidenten das sagt
auch der grüne Ministerpräsident von
Baden-Württemberg das sagen ja auch
andere Ministerpräsidenten von ihnen das
sagen diejenigen die operative
Verantwortung vor Ort haben diejenigen
die sich um das Krankenhauswesen kümmern
müssen diejenigen die sich um die
Gesundheit der Menschen bemühen und
deswegen müssen wir aufhören hier so
eine akademische Diskussion zu führen es
geht um die Menschen in unserem Land
denen sind verantwortlich und jetzt ist
es so ich habe es ja gesagt in den
letzten drei Wochen eine ungeahnte
Dynamik keiner von uns weiß was die
nächsten Tage bringen und deswegen ist
es doch unverantwortlich hier eine
Diskussion zu führen was man heute schon
machen kann und dass das ja bis zum 15
Dezember verlängert werden kann es ist
doch unverantwortlich in dieser
Situation eine Debatte zu führen denen
die operative Verantwortung tragen
Instrumente aus der Hand zu schlagen
Anstalt Ihnen zusätzliche zu geben wenn
man gar nicht weiß wo man hinkommt meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und
deswegen ist es für uns der
entscheidende Punkt deswegen sagen wir
wir brauchen die Fortgeltung der
epidemischen Lage damit eben alle
handlungsinstrumentarien da sind ich
fand es total putzig dass hier von mehr
Rechtssicherheit geredet worden ist wo
sind denn bitteschön unsere Regelungen
angegriffen worden wir haben immer einen
rechtssicheren Rahmen geschaffen und den
einz war es so dass die Umsetzung durch
Rechtsverordnungen fehlerhaft war weil
es natürlich immer im Einzelfall auch an
der Verhältnismäßigkeit zu prüfen ist
also stellen sie doch keine potention
Dörfer auf das hat mit der Realität
nichts zu tun wir haben einen guten
Rechtsrahmen den schlagen Sie uns und
dem Land aus der Hand und sie ersetzen
ihn durch etwas was weniger wert weniger
wertvoll ist dem kann man nicht
zustimmen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
und nichtsdestotrotz anerkennen wir dass
sich der Gesetzentwurf seit der ersten
Lesung vor einer Woche verändert hat wir
sind dankbar dass die Vorschläge die wir
gemacht haben mit aufgenommen worden
sind die führen nämlich erst dazu Herr
Buschmann dass man mit einem solchen
Gesetz weiterkommen kann ihr
ursprünglicher Vorschlag war ein
Abstandsflächen Hygienekonzepte und
Masken das wars und das in dieser
Pandemie ich finde es einfach lächerlich
herzlichen Dank
Thorsten Frey hat hier noch einmal
begründet warum die Union diesem
Gesetzentwurf nicht zustimmen kann Marco
Buschmann hat sich zu Wort gemeldet aber
grüne
Bars geht darüber hinweg
er kommt nicht zu Wort stattdessen jetzt
Manuela Rottmann an rechtspolitikerin
der Bündnisgrünen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Herr Frey ich bin auch verwirrt
ich bin wirklich auch zutiefst verwirrt
wenn vor zwei Tagen der
Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen das Feiern von
Karneval verteidigt und sie heute dafür
kämpfen dass präventive
Schulschließungen wieder möglich sind
dann bin ich verwirrt da frage ich mich
ob Sie die richtigen Prioritäten setzen
sie haben hier den 27 Oktober zitiert am
25 Oktober das gerade mal drei Wochen
her hat ihr Gesundheitsminister gesagt
die epidemische Lage soll Auslaufen ich
bin verwirrt was ist denn los
und ihr aktueller dauerkandidat für den
cdu-vorsitz fordert genau dasselbe ich
bin verwirrt im Vergleich zu Ihnen ist
diese Ampel aus drei Parteien sehr sehr
sortiert Herr frei
Herr Schlacke hat gesagt er möchte gerne
das bewährte Rechtsinstrument verlängern
dieses Rechtsinstrument hat uns in diese
Lage geführt in der wir jetzt sind und
Ihnen fällt nichts ein außer es zu
verlängern und ich weiß genau warum sie
das tun sie müssen sich dann nämlich
nicht mit den Fragen mit den Abwägungen
auseinandersetzen wie wir das gemacht
haben welche Rolle eigentlich Kinder und
Jugendliche in dieser Situation haben ob
sie wieder die letzten sind an die wir
denken ob die Betriebe das tragen können
was für ihnen auferlegen ob es sinnvoll
ist der überwiegende Mehrheit in diesem
Land die sich hat impfen lassen und die
sich auch nach wird impfen lassen denen
zu sagen ihr dürft jetzt gar nichts mehr
völlig egal ob ihr geimpft seid oder
nicht das ist das was Sie uns hier
vorschlagen und sie halten es für
bewährt ich glaube so bekloppt wie Sie
denken sind die Leute da draußen nicht
wir haben eine ernste Situation und es
werden Menschen sterben wir werden es
nicht mehr verhindern können
aber wir können dieser Welle etwas
entgegensetzen und das ist die
Auffrischungsimpfung und das ist das
Impfen und wenn wir das Vertrauen der
Menschen dass das was sie beitragen zum
Brechen dieser Welle dass das ihr Leben
auch leichter macht wenn wir das brechen
dann werden wir vielleicht in Hammer
springen vielleicht hier große Reden
schwingen aber wir verlieren das
Wichtigste was wir in dieser Pandemie
brauchen das ist der Vertrauen und die
Mitwirkungsbereitschaft der Menschen und
das ist ihr Vorschlag
und sie haben vor zwei Tagen noch im
Ausschuss selbst gesagt ja die
Ausgangssperren brauchen wir nicht mehr
heute wollen sie sie wieder
reinschreiben was ist es denn für ein
Kasperltheater sie machen hier einen
Scheindebatte und Sie können nicht
beantworten welche Maßnahmen sie
eigentlich für erforderlich halten die
hier nicht drin stehen
Herr Frey sie haben gesagt wir zwingen
sie etwas zuzustimmen was sie für falsch
halten ich darf daran erinnern dass wir
meine Fraktion in den letzten Jahren bis
an die Schmerzgrenze versucht haben
Konsens herzustellen in diesem Land weil
es der falsche das falsche Thema ist für
parteipolitisches gekränkel und für
Profilneurosen einer schwerbelasteten
Opposition das ist das falsche Thema
und wenn ich weiß dass es in der Union
kluge verantwortungsbewusste Leute gibt
ich will ihnen sagen was ihre Führung
von ihnen verlangt sie verlangt von
Ihnen heute zu Stimmen gegen 3G am
Arbeitsplatz gegen 3G im öffentlichen
Nahverkehr gegen Hilfen für
Krankenhäuser die corona-patienten
behandeln gegen eine Verlängerung der
Regelung in der Künstlersozialkasse all
das verlangt ihre Spitze von ihnen und
was bekommen sie dafür eine
landesöffnungsklausel ohne
Übergangsfristen also das totale Chaos
ich rate Ihnen ab diesen Weg mitzugehen
ja es geht hier auch um die Zukunft der
Union das ist ihre Verantwortung darüber
zu entscheiden aber ich kann Ihnen eines
sagen sie gehen einen schweren Weg wenn
sie einen Weg gehen der erkennen lässt
dass ihnen die Verantwortung in dieser
Situation die Verantwortung für das
Gemeinwesen für die Menschen im
Krankenhäusern weniger wichtig ist als
eine billige Show
Manuela Rottmann
hörbar sauer auf die Unionsfraktion in
der Tat hat die Union ja angekündigt
einsparen als Abgeordneter jetzt mit
einer Kurzintervention ich möchte Frau
Präsidentin weil ich jetzt mehrfach hier
erwähnt worden bin kurz was sagen zuerst
einmal
sie haben mich angesprochen und ich
reagiere darauf das ist das so für eine
kurze Intervention vorgesehen ist das
ist eine schwierige Lager ist übrigens
auch eine schwierige Lage für eine
geschäftsführende Regierung mit
gleichzeitig einer werdenden neuen
Mehrheit da gibt es überhaupt nichts
dran herum zu reden und das ist
herausfordernd in vielerlei Hinsicht und
die Lage ist gleichzeitig Ernst ernst
wie sie vorher das ist ja das Paradox
trotz der Impfquote die wir haben zu
keinem Zeitpunkt in dieser Pandemie
gewesen ist
weil sie mich immer ansprechen dabei ich
habe ihnen am 15 Oktober drei Vorschläge
gemacht
drei Wege aufgezeigt wie der
Handlungsrahmen für die Länder erhalten
werden kann drei
Verlängerung der epidemischen Lage den
28a sehr minimalinvasiv verändern oder
den Absatz 7 den sie jetzt streichen sie
sind keinen dieser Wege gegangen das ist
ihre Entscheidung sie haben sich
entschieden für einen anderen Weg ein
Gesetz zu machen bei dem wir als
geschäftsführende Regierung auch
geholfen haben ihn zu formulieren und zu
entwickeln sie haben viel nachgebessert
sind auf Kritik eingegangen auch das ist
gut richtig und wichtig weil es die
Maßnahmen den Maßnahmenkatalog erweitert
und deswegen ist ja ein Stück beides
richtig ich würde mir wünschen dass die
Länder mehr Möglichkeiten hätten zu
reagieren weil jedenfalls die Dynamik
der letzten drei Wochen in dieser
Dimension glaube ich wenige vorhergesagt
haben und keiner von uns weiß was ich in
den nächsten Wochen entwickelt und
gleichzeitig ist genauso richtig dass
das Gesetz dass sie vorliegen im Zweifel
besser ist als wenn gar keine Regelung
gilt beides ist richtig
aber eins ist auch sehr klar wenn sie
mit ihrer Mehrheit die sie hier haben
und entgegen dem was wir vorgeschlagen
haben auch ich vorgeschlagen habe am
Ende entscheiden diesen Weg zu gehen
dann nehmen Sie bitte nicht immer
irgendjemand anderen als Kronzeugen
dafür oder als punchball dann müssen Sie
wenn Sie diese neue Mehrheit hier sein
wollen diese Verantwortung auch
übernehmen davon kann Ihnen hier keiner
irgendeine Entlastung geben
Frau Dr Rottmann möchten sie reagieren
[Applaus]
Herr Spahn würden
[Musik]
Herr Spahn ich finde das eigentlich gut
was Sie gesagt haben weil wir in ein
Gespräch kommen jetzt und das biete ich
der Union des bieten wir alle der Union
an auch über diese Abstimmung heute
hinaus wir sind auf die Union zugegangen
schon im Hauptausschuss ich habe es in
vier Jahren
Oppositionen nicht einmal erlebt nicht
einmal dass wir noch während einer
laufenden Sitzung eine Änderung an einem
Vorschlag der Regierungsfraktion hatten
das ist diese Woche passiert ich weiß
nicht wie weit wir noch auf sie zu gehen
sollen aber woran es krank ist sie
machen keine konkreten Vorschläge sie
sagen uns nicht was genau sie wollen
kommen Sie auf uns zu wir reden gerne
weiter
vielen Dank
als nächster Redner hat jetzt das Wort
für die FDP-Fraktion Michael teurer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
wir haben die beispiellose Situation
dass derzeit Parteien die über eine
Regierungsbildung verhandeln in die
Verantwortung genommen werden sollen für
Regierungshandeln oder nicht handeln was
wir hier tun ist eine gesetzliche
Grundlage für das Handeln der
Bundesregierung der länderregierung zu
schaffen hier übernehmen die Fraktionen
SPD Grüne und FDP Verantwortung
gleichzeitig auch nach dem was Minister
Spahn gerade gesagt hat kann man die
bisher amtierende und jetzt
geschäftsführende Bundesregierung nicht
aus ihrer Verantwortung für das konkrete
Regierungshandeln entlassen und die
derzeitigen ansteigenden
Infektionszahlen sind ja seit Wochen im
Gange und hätten ja beherztes Handeln
auf der bisherigen Rechtslage erfordert
und deshalb müssen sie sich die Frage
gefallen lassen warum sie nicht
gehandelt haben meine Damen und Herren
Kollege frei hat eingeräumt dass die
Diskussion ihnen verwirrre er hat aber
dann selbst zur Verwirrung beigetragen
und deshalb ist es wichtig hier nochmal
für Klarheit zu sorgen wenn sie
behauptet haben wir SPD FDP und Grüne
hätten von ihrem Gesetzentwurf
abgeschrieben ist es eine klare
Verdrehung der Tatsachen wir haben den
Gesetzesentwurf eingebracht im
Hauptausschuss wurde er behandelt und
sie haben dann ein Änderungsantrag
gemacht sie haben also das Parlament
hier belogen und ich fordere Sie auf das
klarzustellen und ihre unwahre
Behauptung zurückzunehmen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir sind in einer sehr sehr schwierigen
Lage die Inzidenzen in manchen Kreisen
liegen über 1000 und in meinem Wahlkreis
in Karlsruhe ist es jetzt schon so dass
die Intensivstation voll sind und
Patientinnen und Patienten verlegt
werden müssen diese Situation erkennen
wir und wir sind in großer Sorge und wir
leiten aus dieser Situation ab dass die
bisherige Gesetzeslage nicht in der Lage
war diese dramatische Entwicklung zu
verhindern und deshalb schlagen wir mit
dem heutigen Gesetzesentwurf vor
nachzuschärfen die Maßnahmen
treffsicherer zu machen und ja an
einigen Stellen sogar noch zu
verschärfen 3G im Bus und Bahn 3G am
Arbeitsplatz die Öffnung für die Länder
2G einzuführen mit kapazitätsobergrenzen
bei Veranstaltungen das sind klare
Verschärfungen meine Damen und Herren
aber wir sagen an der Stelle auch es ist
erforderlich eine kollektive
Kraftanstrengung in Deutschland zu
mobilisieren denn das Virus lässt sich
nicht durch Paragraphen bekämpfen
sondern nur durch technologische und
soziale Intelligenz und organisatorische
Effizienz und die haben die bisherigen
Regierung vermissen lassen und das haben
muss nachgeschärft werden und wir bitten
deshalb alle in der Union die guten
Willen sind unserem Gesetzesentwurf
heute zuzustimmen
die Gretchenfrage heißt lassen sie sich
impfen ich habe den Eindruck dass das
was die Bundesregierung bisher gemacht
hat ein trauriges Bild abliefert die
Werbekampagne zeigt lass dich impfen
eine Person mit Pflaster im Arm da
wünsche ich mir die Werbekampagne aus
Frankreich die zeigt ein küssendes paar
mit dem Slogan ja der Impfstoff kann
erwünschte Nebenwirkungen haben wir
würden uns freuen wenn mit mehr
Engagement wenn influencer wenn
Künstlerinnen und Künstler wenn
Kulturschaffende auch mit Zielrichtung
auf Milieus mit Migrationshintergrund
jetzt fürs impfen werden und meine Damen
und Herren die Adresse der AFD sie die
sich ja noch nicht mal an die
maskenpflicht hier im Haus halten von
ihnen erwarte ich dass sie mal fürs
impfen eintreten machen sie das endlich
wir brauchen eine höhere Impfquote meine
Damen und Herren impfen und testen ist
die Lösung um diese Pandemie zu
bekämpfen und impfdurchbrüche waren klar
dass die kommen werden tun sie doch
nicht so als ob man das nicht gewusst
hätte trotzdem ist es impfen richtig ein
letzter und persön meine Redezeit zu
Ende ist
meine Damen und Herren einige von ihnen
wissen das wir haben eine Tochter seit
25.07 in der Intensivstation
ich spreche jeden Tag wenn ich kann und
vor Ort bin auch mit Pflegekräften und
ich finde es wirklich schwierig wie die
Situation dort ist wir haben
Pflegenotstand das Personal des
pflegepersonalstärkungsgesetz hat nicht
dazu geführt die Situation zu
entschärfen aber heute an diesem Tag so
zu tun als ob die Fortsetzung der
epidemischen Lage nationaler Tragweite
den Pflegekräfte Mangel beseitigen würde
ist unredlich das ist eine Lüge die
Menschen in der Pflege sagen mir Geld
allein ist es nicht es sind viele
Faktoren die Kinderbetreuung die nicht
mit den Schichtzeiten in Einklang ist
der Parkplatz den man nicht gewährt vor
Ort und viele andere Dinge bis hin zur
Bezahlung und ich würde uns aufrufen
dass wir gemeinsam uns überlegen wie wir
es schaffen dass mehr junge Menschen in
die Pflegeberufe gehen anstatt dass sie
Jura und Volkswirtschaft und BWL
studieren ich bin selber Volkswirt ich
bin der Meinung das müssen wir an der
Stelle machen und hierzu sind wir bereit
ich bin der Meinung dass teurer kommt
hier vorgehen sollten die Lage ist
wirklich dramatisch aber jetzt den
Parteien SPD grün und FDP vorzuwerfen
wir werden für den pflegemangel
verantwortlich das ist unredlich meine
Damen und Herren helfen wir gemeinsam
dass wir mehr Menschen für die Pflege
gewinnen
Michael teurer sehr aufgebracht er hat
selber eine Tochter die auf der
Intensivstation die liegt gute Besserung
dorthin er hat auch gesagt dass
impfdurchbrüche war doch klar dass es
die geben wird vielen in der Bevölkerung
war das leider nicht klar und neben den
ganzen gesetzlichen Dingen würde man
sich natürlich als Mensch auch wünschen
dass die Politiker des die Ärzte einen
noch mehr aufklären auch über die Frage
zum Beispiel wenn man jetzt die dritte
Spritze kriegt welches Präparat macht
Sinn all diese Sachen gehören vielleicht
nicht ins Parlament aber viele Menschen
sind verwirrt
was ich als Abgeordneter hier vom Balkon
sprechen muss zeigt wie sehr ihre
Politik das Land spaltet mein Kollege
hier ist praktisch immun weil sein
antikörperwert
weit er hier oben sitzt kann da unten
jeder geimpfte völlig frei Corona
verbreiten 2G und 3G dienen nicht dem
Gesundheitsschutz 2G und 3G die Ihnen
dazu die Bürger mit massivem Druck zu
willigen Untertanen zu erzielen und da
machen wir als
auch nicht mit
am schlimmsten ist der Umgang mit den
jungen Menschen
2600 feiern in einer Halle in meinem
Wahlkreis in Nürnberg lautstark wetten
das und 200 SPD-Abgeordnete stehen hier
im Bundestag beim Gruppenfoto lachen
zusammen aber Kinder müssen stundenlang
Maske tragen 98 Jugendliche wurden in
Folge der Impfung schwer herzkrank und
es starben seit Februar mehr infolge der
Impfung als an Corona
hunderttausende Kinder
hunderttausende kindererkrankten
psychisch und die Kinderkliniken sind
voll weil wegen Abstand und Masken das
Immunsystem gegen andere Erkrankungen
massiv geschwächt ist diese Maßnahmen
sind ein Himmel schreiendes Verbrechen
an der kommenden Generation und Sie
müssen umgehend beendet werden
was haben der saarländische
Innenminister der Präsident des
Deutschen Olympischen sportbunds und der
Bundestagsabgeordnete Sepp Müller
gemeinsam sie waren alle dreifach
geimpft und haben sich mit Corona
infiziert das sind keine Einzelfälle
über 40 Prozent der corona-toten im
letzten Monat waren laut Robert
Koch-Institut vollständig geimpft das
paul-ehrliche Institut hat über 21.000
schwere Nebenwirkungen und über 1.800
Todesfälle nach Impfung dokumentiert
fakt ist jeden Tag sechs Tote in Folge
der Impfung und 13 vollständig geimpfte
corona-tote jede andere derart
unwirksame Impfung mit solch massiven
Nebenwirkungen wäre schon längst vom
Markt genommen worden
obwohl
obwohl gestern 1400 Intensivbetten
weniger belegt waren als Ende April
reden wir heute über weitgehende
Ermächtigungen der Regierungen wir tun
dir sicher weil jedes dritte
Entschuldigung erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage von Herrn Müller
gerne danke
sie können jetzt leider nicht sehen aber
es steht unter der Tribüne
frau Präsidentin vielen Dank
ja sichert sie haben mich erwähnt wie
sie auch mit einem Selbstbewusstsein
zahlen hier niederlegen die jeglicher
Grundlage entbehren
[Applaus]
meine Erstimpfung war mit Johnson
Johnson
meine booster-impfung war am 20.10
diesen Jahres nachdem das RKI im Oktober
gesagt hat nach vier Wochen soll mit
Johnson Johnson Geburtstag werden
am 27.10 traten wir hier zusammen und am
Freitag darauf habe ich mich mit einem
Schnelltest positiv getestet weil mir
die Nase lief
dieses Symptom hatte ich fünf Tage lang
Gott sei Dank war ich geimpft mir lief
nur die Nase
Herr siechert ich frage sie allen
Ernstes
wenn sie mich hier schon
instrumentalisieren wollen und gegen die
Impfung sprechen kennen sie meinen
handballfreund dessen Namen ich nicht
nenne der Marathon vorher gelaufen ist
in meinem Alter und jetzt nach einem
halben Jahr an corona-infiziert war er
konnte sich nicht impfen lassen weil er
noch nicht der Priorität angehört da
kommt nicht mal mehr die Treppen hoch
wollen sie das Leugnen das Impfung hilft
dass ich als junger Mann nur eine
laufende Nase hatte und bewusst für
Impfung werbe liebe Leute da draußen
lasst euch endlich impfen das ist der
Weg aus der Pandemie
und darum er sichert meine Frage und
meine bitte stellen Sie das klar denn es
entbehrt jeglichen Grundlagen und wenn
nicht dann sagen Sie das bitte
können Sie die Frage noch mal kurz
wiederholen die habe ich nicht
verstanden
[Applaus]
also laut Geschäftsordnung kann er eine
Zwischenbemerkung oder auch Frage
stellen aber sie dürfen jetzt antworten
er sichert dann kann ich gerne antworten
also beschäftigen sie sich endlich mal
mit den Fakten lesen Sie mal die Daten
vom Robert-Koch-Institut lesen Sie die
Daten von paul Ehrlich Institut 170.000
Fälle von Nebenwirkungen über 21.000
Fälle schwerer Nebenwirkungen über 1800
Todesfälle in Folge der Impfung bis Ende
September die Daten bis Ende Oktober
haben wir leider noch nicht und ja ich
freue mich dass bei ihnen diese
Erkrankung nur schwachverlaufen ist aber
das tut sie in über 95 Prozent der Fälle
verläuft eine coronaerkrankung auch bei
ungeimpften nur schwach danke dass ihr
noch mal bestätigen dass sie Geburtstag
gewesen sind dass sie trotzdem Corona
bekommen haben und ich möchte gar nicht
wissen wie viele gebusterte in diesem
Land dann rumlaufen die glauben sie
könnten Corona nicht mehr verbreiten
weil sie hier eine falsche Propaganda an
den Tag legen ständig so tun als würde
diese Impfung dafür sorgen dass die
Menschen nicht mehr erkranken können das
ist nicht der Fall über 40 Prozent der
corona-toten sind laut Robert
Koch-Institut laut dem Institut ihres
gesundheitsbundes
Gesundheitsministeriums sind vollständig
geimpft gewesen hören sie auf den
Menschen zu erzählen diese Impfung würde
sie komplett schützen sondern sorgen Sie
dafür dass diese vulnerablen Gruppen
dass die Menschen am 80 ab 90 gesondert
geschützt sind und hören Sie auf die
Kinder Zugängen wir haben momentan nur
zwei Jugendliche
bundesweit auf den Intensivstationen
zwei Jugendliche bundesweit auf den
Intensivstationen und dafür müssen die
jungen Menschen sich unfassbare
Einschränkungen ertragen das ist
unerträglich Herr sichert sie haben noch
von ihrer Redezeit einen letzten
Schlusssatz übrig
dann fahre ich mit meiner Rede fort
obwohl gestern
1.400 Intensivbetten weniger belegt
waren als Ende April reden wir heute
über weitreichende Einschränkungen wir
tun dies weil jedes dritte intensivbett
aus Personalmangel nicht genutzt werden
kann viele Pflegekräfte haben auch wegen
der massiven corona-maßnahmen ihren
Beruf den Rücken gekehrt anstatt Kinder
und ungeimpfte mit dem
Infektionsschutzgesetz zu gängeln müssen
wir endlich die Attraktivität der
pflegemassiver steigern das ist die
dringlichste Aufgabe in dieser
Legislaturperiode gehen wir sie endlich
an
die nächste Rednerin für die
SPD-Fraktion ist Heike Behrens
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Millionen Menschen in unserem Land sind
denen Angst und Sorge immer mehr
Menschen allen Alters infizieren sich am
Coronavirus und die Zahl der
schwererkrankten steigt täglich die
Situation in unseren Krankenhäusern und
noch mehr auf den Intensivstationen ist
dramatisch
ÄrztInnen und Pflegepersonal leisten
schon heute an vielen Orten mehr als
ihre Kräfte hergeben sie gehen
körperlich seelisch und manchmal auch
ethisch an ihrer Grenzen und Sie liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
verweigern ihre Stimme den dringend
notwendigen Schutzmaßnahmen wollen sie
sich tatsächlich enthalten wie
vorgestern im Hauptausschuss ja einer
ihrer Landesfürsten der erst wenige Tage
im Amt des droht da damit den Bundesrat
dafür zu instrumentalisieren die
heutigen Beschlüsse zu torpedieren wie
klein wollen sie sich eigentlich noch
machen
die Menschen rufen nach Hilfe und
Orientierung und sie antworten mit
Partei taktischen Geplänkel es war ihr
eigener Gesundheitsminister der
gefordert hat das rechtskonstrukt der
epidemischen Lage aufzuheben nicht weil
die Pandemie besiegt wären nein weil es
richtig ist dass der Deutsche Bundestag
über die notwendigen
infektionsschutzmaßnahmen entscheidet
nachdem zwei Drittel der
erwachsenenbevölkerung geimpft sind weil
es richtig ist dass nicht ministerielle
Verordnungen regieren sondern das
gewählte Parlament zu entscheiden hat
weil es richtig ist das regionale und
länderspezifische Maßnahmen von
Landesparlamenten zu beschließen sind
wenn sie einschneidend sind und dafür
schaffen wir heute die Grundlage indem
wir einerseits wichtige bundesweit
einheitliche Maßnahmen beschließen und
andererseits rechtssichere
Handlungsoptionen für die Länder
wir erweitern den Instrumentenkasten
wenn die zweitgrößte Fraktion dieses
Hauses die noch immer geschäftsführend
in
Regierungsverantwortung steht sich hier
und heute einen schlanken Fuß macht und
nicht mehr zur Lösung in dieser größten
Gesundheitskrise die unser Land je
erlebt hat beitragen dann ist das
verantwortungslos und beschämend
alle die in unseren Krankenhäusern um
das Leben von menschenringen alle die
sich um alte und kranke Menschen in
unserem Land kümmern uns seit 18 Monaten
alles tun um sie vor dem Virus zu
schützen und gleichzeitig eine würde von
der Pflege zu leisten sie dürfen von uns
als Politik erwarten dass wir das in
unserer Macht stehende tun
Infektionsgefahren abzuwenden Menschen
zu schützen und unser Gesundheitssystem
funktionsfähig zu halten und deshalb
stimmen sie heute diesen dringend
notwendigen Maßnahmen zu vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Heike Behrens hier mit ihrer wohltuenden
Stimme hat das erregt den Niveau wieder
ein bisschen auf Normalmaß
zurückgebracht dass hier eben herrschte
es ist ja auch ein Thema was bewegt er
ist berichtet ein Abgeordneter davon
dass seine Tochter seit vier Monaten auf
der Intensivstation um ihr Leben ringt
und dann berichtet einen Abgeordneter
das alles nicht so schlimm sei das ist
schwer zu ertragen für den ein oder
anderen der hier sitzt Katja leiket
jetzt von der Unionsfraktion in meinem
Kreis in Main-Kinzig-Kreis haben wir
eine Inzidenz bei den
du bist 14-jährigen von über 400 und wir
sind bei weitem nicht der am stärksten
betroffene Landkreis und den rechtlichen
Rahmen jetzt zu verschlechtern heute
nach dieser Debatte nach Hause zu kommen
und die Pandemie als weniger schlimm zu
erklären das geht nicht
weil ich schon seit einer Stunde 22
Minuten heute hier angeschrien werde
das wird den Familien die Angst haben
müssen vor Kita und Schulschließungen
nicht gerecht und es wird nicht den
Kindern gerecht die ihre Masken
diszipliniert tragen und im Unterricht
sitzen auch das wird ihnen nicht gerecht
und Liebe links gelbe ihr Entwurf nimmt
Rechtssicherheit Frau Dittmer und das
wissen sie auch ganz genau und keiner
versteht warum sie im August noch dafür
gestimmt haben und Frau Göring-Eckardt
es gibt kein Thema und sie sind doch die
ganze Zeit hier auch anwesend gewesen
über das mehr diskutiert wurde als über
die corona-situation in Deutschland und
es ist unser Fraktionsvorsitzender Ralf
Brinkhaus der auch dafür gesorgt hat
und statt hier rumzuschreien ist es viel
wichtiger dass wir darüber sprechen wie
wir durch diese vierte Welle kommen
welche Maßnahmen wir brauchen und ob es
wirklich notwendig ist dass das Berghain
offen gehalten werden muss egal wie hoch
die Inzidenzen sind und ich persönlich
möchte Weihnachten gerne mit meinen
Lieben verbringen lieber statt was und
Clubs auf Teufel kommt raus
aufrechterhalten werden und ich sage es
auch ganz klar ich möchte nicht dass wir
noch mal dahin kommen müssen das Schulen
geschlossen werden und ich weiß nicht
wie sie liebe Frau baerbock ist daheim
ihren Kindern erklären ich werde in
dieser Lage definitiv nicht für ihre
Fehlentscheidung hier gerade stehen
und lieber Herr Buschmann über die FDP
kann man sich ja die ganze Zeit nur
wundern sie haben schon im August die
Fortführung der epidemischen Lage
abgelehnt weil ihr alles irgendwie
unproblematisch sein und die cdu/csu
hatte damals recht und wir haben heute
auch recht es braucht die epidemische
Lage um schnell handeln zu können auch
und gerade um Familien zu schützen wie
alle sollten auch mal Lernerfolge in den
Management der Pandemie an den Tag legen
wir alle wissen was Eltern mit
Kleinkindern was Erzieherin in den Kitas
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer in den Vereinen
und so weiter in unserem Land geleistet
haben und wie schwierig die Situation
für Schwangere ist wie problematisch die
Situation für Jugendliche und
Studierende und Auszubildende ist und
ihnen sollten wir alle einmal ein großes
Dankeschön sagen für ihre Disziplin und
uns auch entschuldigen wenn ich jede
Maßnahme sofort Angst hat aber gerade
deshalb müssen wir jetzt aus dieser Lage
lernen und aus dem was wir bisher
beschlossen haben und wir müssen jetzt
klar die Lebensbereiche von Familien
schützen die vulnerablen Gruppen in
diesem Land lieber FDP sind ungeimpfte
Kinder die Menschen in den Pflegeheimen
die wunderbaren Gruppen sind nicht
irgendwelche Individualisten die den
einfachen Satz nicht verstehen dass die
Freiheit des Einzelnen dort aufhört wo
die Freiheit des anderen anfängt
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren hier in
dieser Stadt in der Hauptstadt in Berlin
ist die Inzidenz von über 1300 bei den
10 bis 14-Jährigen es sind aktuell schon
fünf Schulen im wechselunterricht von
einem auf den anderen Tag werden Schulen
beschlossen und ich teile die Kritik der
Eltern vor Ort und deren Forderung es
sind die Schulen die als letztes
schließen sollten und vielleicht kann
uns der geschäftsführende Regierende
Bürgermeister von Berlin der ja hier ist
vielleicht kann er uns erklären wie das
zusammenpasst in so einer Situation die
Beendigung der pandemischen Lage
auszurufen
Liebe ampelfraktionen wir brauchen keine
[Applaus]
parteipolitischen Spielchen die ihren
Koalitionsverhandlungen geschuldet sind
bitte passen Sie gut auf dieses Land in
Zeiten der Pandemie auf herzlichen Dank
Katja leikert von der cdu/csu der
nächste Redner Detlef Müller von der SPD
ist im Zivilberuf Lokomotivführer und es
geht in diesem Gesetz ja unter anderem
auch über den öffentlichen Verkehr man
darf dann demnächst nur noch mit 3G zu
steigen allerdings wie das genau
kontrolliert werden soll das ist völlig
unklar Detlef Müller sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir befinden uns in der vierten und
hoffentlich letzten großen Welle der
corona-pandemie die inzidenzzahlen
steigen in vielen Regionen und ich komme
aus Sachsen auf bisher nicht gekannte
Höhen solange wir keine ausreichende
Impfquote erreichen müssen in allen
Bereichen Maßnahmen ergriffen werden die
für die Sicherheit der Menschen in
unserem Land besorgen das tun wir mit
dieser Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes auch für den
Bereich Mobilität und Verkehr Sie meine
Damen und Herren kennen es doch aus
eigenem Erleben insofern sie öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel nutzen
volle Bahn dicht gedrängt im Bus im
Hinterkopf aber das Wissen um das hohe
Infektionsgeschehen und nicht jeder
Fahrgast trägt die Maske auch
tatsächlich passend alles zusammen kein
gutes Gefühl wir müssen die Mobilität
für alle Nutzerinnen und Nutzer
öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel auch im
Sinne des Infektionsschutzes sicher
gestalten deswegen ist sie nun kommende
3g-regel in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln
für Fahrgäste und Personal nur
folgerichtig und wird auch allen Teilen
begrüßt unter anderem auch durch den
Deutschen Städtetag sie schließt ja
Kleinwächter grundsätzlich niemanden aus
ermöglicht aber allen eine höhere
Sicherheit indem sie klarstellt dass
eben nur geimpfte genesene oder
getestete Personen öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel nutzen
die große Frage lautete aber wie soll
das funktionieren wer soll diese
Regelung auch durchsetzen wer sie
kontrollieren und deshalb war es uns
wichtig diese Regeln praktikabel zu
gestalten wir setzen auf
stichprobenartige Prüfungen anstelle von
Zutrittskontrollen die in unserem
öffentlichen Verkehr auch gar nicht
umsetzbar werden meine Damen und Herren
und es wird im Regelfall eben auch nicht
die Zugbegleiterin und nicht der
Busfahrer sein die beziehungsweise der
diese Regeln durch oder umsetzen muss
firmeneigne oder externe
Sicherheitsunternehmen sind gefordert
wie jetzt schon bei den
fahrausweiskontrollen auch die
Bundespolizei und die Polizei in der
Länder sowie die Ordnungsbehörden der
Kommunen sind gefragt diese
Stichprobenkontrollen durchzuführen und
sie auch zu unterstützen
zur praktischen Umsetzbarkeit gehört
aber auch das schülerverkehre von der
3g-regel ausgenommen sind denn es ist
schlichtweg nicht möglich das Kinder und
Jugendliche sich vor davor zur Schule
testen lassen zumal sie bereits jetzt
zwei bis drei Mal die Woche im
Unterricht getestet werden und wir haben
auch die Taxi Verkehre von den
dreijährigen ausgenommen denn Taxen
werden eben nicht von großen Gruppen die
untereinander nicht weiteren Kontakt
stehen genutzt meine Damen und Herren
all diese Regelungen werden die
Sicherheit im öffentlichen
Personenverkehr erhöhen klar ist aber
auch dass all diese Regeln nichts nützen
wenn einzelne Menschen nicht bereit sind
Rücksicht aufeinander zu nehmen
Rücksicht indem sie ihre mund-nase Maske
ebenso tragen dass sie eben genau Mund
und Maske Munde Nase bedeckt und vor
allem Rücksicht indem sie sich ihre
eigenen Verantwortung bewusst werden und
auch in impfangebot in Anspruch nehmen
vielen Dank für eure
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR Jan Marco Luczak
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich möchte gerne auf einen Punkt
eingehen der hat mich echt in dieser
Debatte geärgert und es hat mich echt
massiv geärgert dass alle Redner von der
Ampel alle der Union hier Parteipolitik
vorgeworfen haben und da will ich Ihnen
mal den Spiegel verhalten da will ich
Ihnen mal den Spiegel Verhalten was
haben Sie denn jetzt in den letzten zwei
Wochen gemacht sie haben uns dem
Deutschen Bundestag ein Entwurf
vorgelegt für Corona der absolut
unzureichend war der absolut
unzureichend weil sie haben sich sie
haben sich in die Geiselhaft von der FDP
leben lassen von einem falsch
verstandenen freiheitsdogma das nicht
sieht das Freiheit immer auch
Verantwortung bedeutet und Verantwortung
so unbequem Entscheidung sie haben
Rücksicht genommen auf die FDP und zwar
aus reinem Partei politischen Kalkül
weil sie die Ampel nicht gefährden
wollten weil sie die
Koalitionsverhandlungen nicht gefährden
wollen und jetzt kommen Sie uns bitte
hier nicht mit Parteipolitik das
Gegenteil ist der Fall
und sie wissen ja auch sie wissen ganz
genau dass es so ist und deswegen haben
sie auch ganz hektisch nachgebessert an
ihrem Entwurf sie haben auf massiven
Druck den wir hier als Union im
Parlament gemacht haben auf massiven
Druck den die Öffentlichkeit gemacht
haben auf den konkreten Vorschlag den
wir im Hauptausschuss als Union gemacht
haben da haben sie ihren Gesetzentwurf
nachgebessert aber ich sag ihm mal was
das reicht immer noch nicht aus und
diese Feststellung dass ihr Entwurf
nicht ausstreicht das ist keine
Parteipolitik hören sich mal an was der
Chef vom RKI was Herr will er sagt der
sagt Bars und Clubs das sind die
Hotspots das sind die pandemietreiber
die müssen geschlossen werden können
nach ihrem Gesetzentwurf wird das
zukünftig nicht möglich sein der sagt
Großveranstaltung die müssen abgesagt
werden können nach ihrem Gesetzentwurf
wird das nicht Möglichkeit sein ihr
instrumentenkassen den Sie uns hier
präsentieren der ist zukünftig kleiner
als das was wir nach der epidemischen
Lage hätten das ist die Wahrheit meine
Damen und Herren
und wenn Sie schon und wenn Sie schon
dem Chef des RKI Herrn Wieler nicht
glauben schenken wollen denn nun
wirklich unverdächtig ist Parteipolitik
machen zu dürfen dann glauben sie
vielleicht liebe Kolleginnen eine SPD
ihrem Gesundheitsexperten Karl
Lauterbach ich habe ihn ja schon vor
einer Woche hier adressiert Herr
Lauterbach hat gestern noch einmal
gesagt wenn zwei gehen nicht wirken
sollte dann werden wir einen Lockdown
benötigen dann werden wir ein Lockdown
benötigen und Herr Drosten Herr Drosten
der hat uns in der Anhörung am Montag
gesagt 2G wird aus seiner Sicht nicht
ausreichen das möchte ich mal
feststellen ich möchte gerne zur
ausführen ihre Experten Herr Lauterbach
ihre Experten Herr Drosten den sie in
die Anhörung berufen haben der sagt
ihnen ihr Gesetzentwurf wird nicht
ausreichend weil genau das alles nämlich
nicht möglich ist nach ihrem
Gesetzentwurf wird es nicht möglich sein
Restaurants zu schließen nach ihrem
Gastronomie zu schließen nach ihrem
Gesetzen und wo wird es nicht möglich
sein Bars und Clubs zu schließen nach
ihrem Gesetzentwurf wird nicht möglich
sein Veranstaltung zu untersagen
all nicht möglich sein und sie wissen ja
auch
selbstbeschuss haben sie schon
ange seriöser Politik nichts zu tun was
Sie an dieser Stelle hier machen meine
Damen und Herren Herr lucczak erlauben
sie Zwischenfragen einmal von Herrn
Marco Buschmann und auch Karl Lauterbach
haben sich gemeldet in welcher
Reihenfolge ist mir egal aber sehr Herr
Busch wenn Sie erlauben dann Herr
buschmann
Herr Kollege lutschak den wir für
gewöhnlich als ein sachlich gut
informierten Kollegen kennen möchte ich
fragen
möchte ich fragen ob sie zur Kenntnis
nehmen wollen dass es natürlich nach
neuem Recht möglich ist
Freizeitveranstaltungen zu untersagen
und
Freizeiteinrichtungen zu schließen wenn
die Landesregierung dafür in die
Landtage gehen und dass ihr Vorwurf den
Sie hier erhoben haben dass das nicht
möglich sein nur dann stimmen würde wenn
es sich um Landesregierung handelt die
gegen den Willen ihres Landtags handeln
wollen hat eins
und A2 möchte ich Sie fragen wenn es
denn so ist was sie ja hier sagen dass
sie den Lockdown wollen dass sie
gastronomieschließung pauschal wollen
dass Sie Schulschließung pauschal wollen
warum wird es dann nicht dort von den
Ministerpräsidenten gemacht wo die Lage
heute am verheerendsten ist nämlich in
Sachsen und in Bayern
lieber Herr Kollege Buschmann ich kenne
sie ja schon seit langem und wir
schätzen auch gegenseitig uns und sie
sind auch ein sehr guter Jurist und
deswegen wundert mich es ein bisschen
schon dass sie ganz offensichtlich ihren
eigenen Gesetzentwurf nicht richtig
gelesen haben wenn 28a Absatz 8 steht
nämlich genau das drin was ich hier
referiert habe wenn wir keine
epidemische Notlage hier im Bundestag
feststellen dann haben die Länder
zukünftig die Möglichkeit in den
Parlamenten bestimmte Maßnahmen zu
beschließen
ausgenommen und zwar ausdrücklich
ausgenommen ist genau das was ich gesagt
habe es ist ausgeschlossen das
Restaurants untersagt wird es ist
angeschlossen werden das Veranstaltungen
lesen Sie doch bitteschön ihren
Gesetzentwurf genauso ist es so und zu
ihrem Lockdown ich sage nicht dass wir
einen Lockdown wollen ich weiß auch
nicht ob wir einen Lockdown brauchen ich
bin Jurist ich bin kein Virologe aber
ich kann Ihnen sagen wenn wir in zwei
oder drei Wochen feststellen dass die
Inzidenzen noch weiter hoch gegangen
sind wir haben eine Inzidenz von 337 sie
haben
65.000 Neuinfektionen das wird bedeuten
dass in einigen wenigen Wochen über 500
Menschen gestorben sein werden da können
wir nichts mehr dran ändern und deswegen
will ich dass wir das ganze
Instrumentarium haben was wir brauchen
um weitere Infektionen und damit Tode zu
verhindern das ist der Punkt worum es
geht
Herr Dr lutschak erlauben sie auch eine
Zwischenbemerkung dazwischenfrage von
Professor Dr lauterbach
vielen Dank Lucia
ich möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass ich sehr früh auf die jetzt
kommende Welle hingewiesen habe und das
sage ich nicht aus Rechthaberei sondern
dass das sage ich nicht aus Rechthaberei
sondern das sage ich weil es auch hier
in den Zusammenhang passt ich habe am
wenigsten am wenigsten Erfolg bei der
Überzeugungsarbeit gehabt bei den
Ministerpräsidenten der Union habe ich
den wenigsten Erfolg gehabt ich habe zum
Beispiel davor gewarnt dass wir den
Masken ich habe davor gewarnt dass wir
die maskenpflicht in Nordrhein-Westfalen
aufheben als die Zahlen schon Anstiegen
ich habe durchgehend ich habe
durchgehend zu zwei g geraten das ist in
keinem der Bundesländer eingeführt
worden für die sie jetzt sprechen somit
wenn sie jetzt wenn sie jetzt fordern
wir müssten Möglichkeiten haben den
Lockdown wieder einzuführen wieso haben
Sie sich denn dann nicht persönlich
dafür eingesetzt wenigstens das 2G hören
als es noch geholfen hätte wir werden
bald in einer Situation kommen wo wir
tatsächlich genau das machen müssen was
Herr Buschmann korrekterweise
beschrieben hat wir werden in den
besonders betroffenen gebeten
tatsächlich über lokale Schließungen
nachdenken müssen wenn wir es nicht
anders in den Griff bekommen das ist
aber eine Selbstverständlichkeit zum
jetzigen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt hätten
wir viel mehr Spielraum wenn Sie den
Spielraum nutzen würden den wir Ihnen
seit Wochen geboten haben und sie hätten
ja auch jetzt die epidemische Lage gilt
ja über Wochen hinweg helfen können dass
wir es gar nicht in die Situation
gekommen wären in die wir jetzt geraten
sind
lieber Kollege Lauterbach mir und ich
glaube uns allen wer viel mehr damit
gewinnt gewesen wenn Sie Ihre
Überzeugungsarbeit nicht bei
Ministerpräsidenten der Union der SPD
von den Grünen genutzt hätten sondern
wenn sie Überzeugungsarbeit in ihrer
eigenen Fraktion geleistet hätten das
ist doch der Punkt sie legen uns hier
etwas vor was unzureichen ist sie sagen
doch selbst wir brauchen möglicherweise
ein Lockdown sie haben es gerade
bestätigt das was sie uns jetzt vorlegen
mit ihrer Verweigerung die epidemische
Lage zu verlängern schließen Sie das
genau aus und deswegen ist ihre
Argumentation in sich brüchig sie ist
widersprüchig und sie ist nicht
glaubwürdig das muss ich ihnen einfach
sagen Herr Kollege ich schätze sie sonst
aber das ist nicht in Ordnung
und jetzt jetzt will ich noch am Schluss
noch einen Punkt auch noch sagen weil ja
hier diverse Male auch die Länder
angesprochen sind wir wissen nicht wie
der Bundesrat morgen entscheiden wird
wir haben das gehört aber ich kann Ihnen
sagen wir als Union sind bereit auch
hier in der nächsten Woche sofort eine
Sondersitzung des Deutschen Bundestages
zu machen ein Vermittlungsausschuss
einzusetzen damit wir diese Probleme bei
dem von ihnen vorgelegten Gesetzentwurf
noch lösen können und deswegen hören sie
auf mit ihrer Parteipolitik während wir
Verantwortung gerecht als Ampel stimmen
Sie der Verlängerung der epidemischen
Lage zu vielen Dank
ja der Herr lutschak hat es jetzt
angesprochen die Union scheint hier
tatsächlich über die Länderkammer Druck
erzeugen zu wollen dieses Gesetz was
hier gleich verabschiedet werden soll
ist zustimmungspflichtig im Bundesrat
und wenn der Bundesrat ein
Vermittlungsausschuss anruft dann wird
es kompliziert meine Damen und Herren
denn dann müsste es einen
Vermittlungsausschuss geben dafür hat
der Bundestag sich noch gar nicht
aufgestellt es wird alles weiter
verzögern das sollte sich die Union
glaube ich noch mal überlegen Dirk wie
sie jetzt als Letzter reden für die SPD
diskutiert haben über wirksame
Instrumente die heute durch den
Gesetzentwurf auf den Weg gebracht
worden sind bin ich Sepp Müller sehr
dankbar weil Sepp Müller hat auf eins
noch mal hingewiesen in seiner
Intervention oder Zwischenfrage das
entscheidende um aus dieser Pandemie
rauszukommen ist das Impfen und wir
müssen alle zusammen das Impfen
beschleunigen wir müssen das Boostern
voranbringen und das ist eine
Verantwortung die wir alle haben im
Deutschen Bundestag in den Bundesländern
in den komm und da müssen wir
vorankommen und ich muss
und ich muss da mal deutlich sagen Herr
sichert eine Fraktion die es bei dieser
Lage in der wir uns befinden in einigen
Regionen dramatisch nötig hat auf zwei
Etagen im Deutschen Bundestag Platz zu
nehmen die hat den Ernst der Lage nicht
verstanden und ich sage Ihnen das mal
ganz deutlich
und ich sage das ganz deutlich und
zitiere Albert Einstein zwei Dinge sind
unendlich das Universum und die
menschliche Dummheit bei der
menschlichen Dummheit bin ich mir noch
nicht ganz sicher und das hat der
Beitrag von der Sicherheit gezeigt und
das muss ich so deutlich sagen das war
faktenfrei und es zeigt doch da wo sie
Ergebnisse erzielt ist die Impfquote
unten sie tragen durch ihre Politik mit
Verantwortung für diese Situation in der
wir in einigen Bundesländern sind
und jetzt muss ich zu den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Union und ihren
Redebeiträgen noch mal einiges aufführen
Frau Dr leikert Herr Dr lutschak sie
kennen die Gesetzesvorlage nicht das
muss sich eindeutig sagen
das was sie hier streuen sind
Falschinformation
Diskotheken und Clubs können nach der
Rechtslage die wir auf den Weg bringen
von den Ländern geschlossen werden alles
was Sie hier suggerierend ist falsch
und ich muss das auch schon deutlich
sagen das was ich diese Woche im
Hauptausschuss erlebt habe war dass sie
einen Änderungsantrag eingebracht haben
wo sie gesagt haben dass die Frist die
Übergangsregelung verlängert werden
sollte das war ein sinnvoller Vorschlag
wir sind dem auch gefolgt danach haben
sie Punkte eingebracht dass sie das Wort
insbesondere zusätzlich drin haben
wollen das haben sie auf den Weg
gebracht wenn sie aber sehen dass über
die länderöffnungsklausel der Absatz 1
aktiviert werden kann mit dem Wort
insbesondere dann ist auch dieser Punkt
in den Gesetz rechtstechnisch drin und
das heißt sie haben gar keine Argumente
mehr warum sie fachlich nicht zustimmen
das ist rein politisch was sie hier
abziehen und ich sage das ganz deutlich
das was sie als cdu/csu hier heute
machen und das zeichnet sich glaube ich
in den Akt für die Arbeit der kommenden
vier Jahre in der Opposition das ist das
Motto erst die Partei dann das Land und
das ist unverantwortlich was sie machen
ich habe mehrere Anfragen einer
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung
einmal von der oben von der afd-fraktion
würden sie die Frage Bemerkung zulassen
das hat keinen Mehrwert in der Debatte
heute
dann habe ich eine zweite Zwischenfrage
von Herrn lussak aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion würden sie die zulassen
sehr gerne
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Wiese dass sie
die Frage zulassen ich habe ja schon
jetzt gerade gesprochen ich hätte mich
auch nicht mehr gemeldet aber das was
sie hier sagen das kann nicht
unwidersprochen bleiben wenn sie jetzt
sagen wir hätten ihren Gesetzentwurf
ihre Änderungsanträge nicht gelesen dann
muss ich jetzt mal an der Stelle
zitieren in 28a Absatz 8 den Sie uns
jetzt hier vorschlagen da steht drin
dass nach dem Ende der epidemischen
Notlage wenn die Landesparlamente es
entsprechend beschließen dann sind die
Maßnahmen möglich und dann heißt es
weiter folgende Schutzmaßnahmen sind
ausgeschlossen die Untersagung von
Veranstaltungen die Untersagung von
Ansammlung die öfter sagen voll Aufzügen
und dann heißt es weiter auch den Absatz
1 Nummer 14 das ist die Gastronomie das
sind die Bars und die Clubs auch die
werden zukünftig nicht ausgeschlossen
und untersagt werden können das einzige
das einzige was möglich ist und deswegen
streuen Sie den Leuten bitte nicht Sand
in her und das einzige was möglich ist
dass ein Gesundheitsamt in einem
konkreten Einzelfall eine bestimmte
fließt das ist etwas völlig anderes als
eine generelle Untersagung was wir
möglicherweise brauchen
[Applaus]
Herr Kollege Dr Lucek das ist falsch und
das sage ich hier auch noch mal
eindeutig
und ich kann und dann kommen wir in eine
juristische Debatte rein Ihnen gerne die
Lektüre des Kommentars zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz empfehlen die
teilweise Leute aus dem
Bundesgesundheitsministerium und
Bundesinnenministerium verfasst haben
das steht das was ich gerade hier
geschildert habe eindeutig drin wir
können gerne gleich zusammen da
reinschauen und ich gebe Ihnen noch ein
Hinweis was wir gemacht haben wir haben
zudem die kapazitären Beschränkungen
verschärft das heißt Sie können auch für
diese Bereiche die kapazitären
Beschränkungen fast gegen Null fahren
sie können gleichzeitig zwei g plus
anordnen in den Bereichen wenn Sie einen
flächendeckenden Lockdown wollen dann
müssen sie das hier konkret sagen und
sich nicht ausreden
und sehr geehrter Herr Dobrind ich muss
Ihnen mal eines sagen aktueller Stand wo
ich hier am Podium stehe gilt die
derzeitige Rechtslage ihr
Ministerpräsident in Bayern hätte
handeln können er hat nichts getan er
hat nichts auf den Weg gebracht er ist
verantwortlich für die Situation im
Freistaat Bayern und dass sie sich hier
rausreden wollen und mit dem Finger auf
den Bund zeigen dass es unredlich das
ist verantwortungslos dafür was in
Bayern stattfindet trägt Markus Söder
die Verantwortung er hat es unterlassen
zu handeln und das muss man hier mal
sehr deutlich auch sagen
ich komme zum Schluss und das ist das
Wichtigste was ich am Anfang gesagt habe
das Entscheidende ist impfen impfen
impfen und alle Bundesbürger die draußen
jetzt zuschauen lassen sie sich impfen
gehen Sie zu den Impfzentren das müssen
wir voranbringen denn das ist der
einzige entscheidende Weg um aus dieser
Situation rauszukommen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
soll das der Antrag einer
Kurzintervention sein verstehe ich den
Zwischenruf richtig dann hat jetzt das
Wort für eine Kurzintervention
aus der Fraktion
[Musik]
die Frau Hasselmann ist PGF und die hat
mir das gerade zugerufen also also
insofern ist es jetzt eine
Kurzintervention von der Kollegin
Rottmann aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen bitte sie haben das Wort es
vielen Dank es geht ganz schnell ich
lese vor trage vor aus der Begründung zu
Absatz 8 möglich bleiben danach unter
den Voraussetzungen des Absatz 8
Untersagungen Beschränkungen von
Freizeitveranstaltungen zum Beispiel
Weihnachtsmärkte nach Absatz 1 Nr 5 und
ausdrücklich möglich weil wir den auch
nicht eingeschränkt haben bleibt die
Untersagung von Kulturveranstaltungen zu
meinem Bedauern aber so ist es
Untersagung von Sportveranstaltungen ist
drin nur Sportausübung nicht genau
doch ich habe es ihnen gerade vorgelesen
hören sie halt zu Herr frei aber ich
lese ihn gerne auch noch mal vor danke
schön
[Musik]
auch nicht auch natürlich ein Problem
für Juristen sechs Meinungen das ist
immer etwas schwierig das aber ein
Gesetzestext schon bevor abgestimmt wird
zu Unklarheiten führt ist auch nicht
ideal Herr Bochmann richtig
von der AFD auch mit einer
Kurzintervention antwortet wenn er
möchte übrigens auf der Tribüne also
weder geimpft noch genesen also ich bin
ja vorhin nicht gehört worden oder meine
Frage durfte nicht gestellt werden an
den Herrn Wiese ich gebe zu bedenken vor
dem Antrag oder vor dem Beschluss dass
jeder
Abgeordnete hier im Haus
sollte sich dessen bewusst sein und das
wäre mein Wunsch dass wenn jemand
nachweislich durch die Impfung zu Tode
kommt er persönlich in seinem Wahlkreis
die Verantwortung übernimmt und sich den
Angehörigen verbliebenen hinter
gegenüberstellt danke
ich gebe jetzt zuerst
Dirk Wiese das Wort wenn er darauf
antworten möchte Herr Wiese
sie bekommen der Herr lutschak bekommt
gleich auch noch das Wort aber erst der
Redner von gerade Dirk Wiese und gleich
darf der Herr Lutscher weil er direkt
angesprochen wurde auch noch mal
Stellung nehmen
so jetzt glaube ich funktioniert
Entschuldigung erstmal möchte ich der
Kollegin Rottmann in allen Punkten
zustimmen das ist juristisch völlig
korrekt und sind die richtigen
Ausführungen wie sie nach der
derzeitigen Rechtslage wenn wir sie so
beschließen auch zukünftig möglich sind
dann möchte ich gerne auf den Kollegen
auf dem Tribüne eingehen sie haben von
Verantwortung gesprochen wenn sie mit
ihren faktenbasierten Informationen die
Verantwortung dafür tragen dass eine
ganze Zahl von ungeimpften und wenn wir
uns die Inzidenz anschauen in Sachsen in
Bayern dann ist die Inzidenz bei den
Geimpften unter 100 bei denjenigen die
ungeimpft sind weit über 1000 wenn Sie
die schweren Verläufe sehen bei den
ungeimpften die sie auch noch bestärken
dass sie sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
betragen Sie dafür die Verantwortung für
diese schweren Verläufe für die vielen
Toten die wir momentan sehen das ist
ihrer Politik den Regionen geschuldet
und da tragen sie als AFD eine
Mitverantwortung
so und da der Herr Lutscher gerade von
Frau Rottmann direkt angesprochen wurde
teile ich Ihnen auch noch mal das Wort
vielen Dank auch auf die Gefahr dass es
jetzt zu einem juristischen Symposium
hier wird aber das noch mal vor Rottmann
das kann man so nicht stehen lassen hat
eins sie wissen ganz genau dass die
Begründung eines Gesetzentwurfes und
zumal eines Änderungsantrages etwas ganz
anderes ist als der Text des Gesetzes
und im Text des Gesetzes steht
ausdrücklich drin dass es ausgeschlossen
ist nochmal ausdrücklich ausgeschlossen
ist das Veranstaltungen untersagt werden
es ist ausdrücklich ausgeschlossen dass
Gastronomie das Bars und Clubs untersagt
werden und da kommen sie auch nicht um
hin mit deren fragwürdigen Verweis auf
die Begründung was da dann doch noch
möglich ist Weihnachtsmärkte wenn Sie
das da reinschreiben das sind doch die
Hotspots sind doch die Bars und die
Clubs und die haben sie hier
ausdrücklich ausgeschlossen deswegen
nochmal streuen Sie den Menschen hier
nicht Sand in die Augen sie verringern
hier den Instrumentenkasten und setzten
damit die Gesundheit der Menschen auf
das Spiel meine Damen und Herren
so und weil es um klare Informationen
geht muss ich mich auch noch mal
korrigieren auf der Tribüne sitzen
Menschen die keine Auskunft geben wollen
wie ihr Impfstatus ist ob sie überhaupt
haben ob sie genesen sind etc das ist
glaube ich dann die korrekte Äußerung
um ihre Aufmerksamkeit wir kommen jetzt
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes und weiterer
Gesetze anlässlich der Aufhebung der
Feststellung der epidemischen Lage von
nationaler Tragweite hierzu liegen
mehrere Erklärungen zur Abstimmung vor
der Hauptausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksachen 78 und 89 den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache 15 in der ausschussfassung
anzunehmen es liegt ein Änderungsantrag
der Fraktion der cdu/cs auf Drucksache
90 vor über den wir zuerst abstimmen wer
stimmt für diesen Änderungsantrag
das ist die
cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das
ist die Fraktion DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen FDP und die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht damit ist der
Änderungsantrag abgelehnt ich bitte nun
diejenigen die dem Gesetzentwurf der
Fraktion der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das ist die SPD-Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen die FDP-Fraktion Gegenstimmen
[Musik]
das ist die cdu/csu-fraktion die
afd-fraktion Enthaltung die Fraktion DIE
LINKE damit ist der Gesetzentwurf in
zweiter Beratung angenommen jetzt kommen
wir zur dritten Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung die Fraktion der AFD
hat namentliche
Abstimmung verlangt die Abstimmung
erfolgt in der westlobby und auf der
Tribüne
ich weise darauf ich weise ausdrücklich
darauf hin dass sie bei Verlassen des
Sitzplatzes zur Teilnahme an der
namentlichen Abstimmung die Pflicht zum
Tragen einer medizinischen
mund-nase-bedeckung haben und ich und
ich gegen Verstöße diese Pflicht mit den
Mitteln des parlamentarischen
Ordnungsrecht Ahnen werde ich bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer
hierauf zu achten das gilt übrigens auch
für die später folgende namentliche
Abstimmung sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer
Stimme nach Eröffnung der Abstimmung 30
Minuten Zeit bitte gehen Sie nicht alle
gleichzeitig zur Abstimmung es stehen
mehrere Uhren zur Verfügung gleich wenn
ich die Abstimmung eröffne
erfolgt noch eine weitere Abstimmung
deshalb bitte ich Sie noch einen Moment
im Raum zu bleiben die Schriftführerin
und Schriftführer
haben ihre Plätze eingenommen soweit ich
ja der Daumen ist hoch das sieht gut aus
das ist der Fall ich eröffne damit die
namentliche Abstimmung über den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen der SPD
Bündnis 90 Grüne und FDP die
abstimmungsurnen werden um
11 Uhr
geschlossen das Ergebnis der
namentlichen Abstimmung über den
Gesetzentwurf wird Ihnen dann später
nach dem Tagesordnungspunkt 3 bekannt
gegeben erst danach stimmen wir über den
über die Entschließungsanträge der
Fraktion der cdu/csu sowie der Fraktion
DIE LINKE ab über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu werden wir auch später
namentlich abstimmen